there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody here we are once again how
come you can see my laptop in the [ __ ]
now i guess i didn't know
where you seen the laptop i just saw it
like right there okay actually it needs
to kind of move a little bit towards you
the camera
well i moved it earlier because it was
like i don't know what the [ __ ] it's
doing it's kind of stuck back there it's
like falling off of the back of the desk
here
yeah i guess that's about right yeah
that's usually right right because like
i said cut off because if you move it i
mean if you move it it just
see
yeah that's right then yeah but yeah i
use spock as my [ __ ] aim well i do
too but the thing about it is that it
gets like i said it gets moved because
pookie is up here farting around and
it falls off the desk and all kind of
crazy [ __ ] is going on back there yeah
so that way see
i am in and you are in
like that and spock is [ __ ] leaning
up up against the wall like that see him
with his yeah like that he's selling
crack
he's like i'm holding i'm holding
yeah i thought he was just back there
like disapproving now he's sitting on
our shenanigans
yeah he's he's watching yeah i mean
creepily
it's funny because like every now and
then i'll like come through here like in
the middle of the night to like to go to
the bathroom i don't really do it
anymore but like for a while i was just
kind of like oh there's a person oh yeah
that's right it's just fun
yeah because it just like looks like a
shadow person get up take a leak at
night and look down and look down the
hallway and i see him standing there
yeah see
the thing yeah
i'm used to it now so it doesn't really
bother me anymore so it's like i just
hope nobody breaks into the house one
day and stands that's the spot cause
i'll just like not put a spock out front
so when they break in [ __ ] he's sitting
there on guard
and everybody's like oh [ __ ]
pimp spock
yeah so uh hey everybody it's wednesday
meeting you exam yeah and uh yeah dj
maniac says too many night clubs this
week i've been out every other night
since last friday i have two more this
friday and sunday yeah we actually have
uh
sunday night is memento mori at the new
place
um you know there's some other like
dimitri's djing at mannequins on friday
night but i don't know if i can like
afford to go to both things especially
because the
momentum thing is so far
and we haven't driven to that place yet
so i'm not actually going to knock us
out a couple hundred dollars to hit both
of them that's yeah so i'm thinking well
we'll save it for sunday because i do
actually want to um check out the new
place all right all right and see uh
what that's all about yeah so you know
because mannequins is closer and so it's
like easier to go
some other time yeah but
you know next month it's going to be
better i think anyway it's going to be
easy better on us
money wise well i hope so i never
you know okay this year this month did
it okay this month uh so far okay you're
on track i think so okay i think so good
we'll see i've been getting some like uh
i've been getting some jobs yeah grandpa
says if something we'll get some super
chats tonight
[Laughter]
you're shameless yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm pimping her so that's what i mean
yeah i never have like i never have the
audacity to do that
we're not in it we're not on only fans
yet
no i'll pimp you one breast in hate
chant
making all kinds of money
making all kinds of money we make that
porn money
making porn making poor money i feel
like you we probably would lose money we
probably would because well i kind of
feel like now it's who makes porn money
anymore it's like more money yeah they
make more money it's just got to be
[ __ ] crazy
that's what i mean you got to be like
crazy [ __ ] you feel like titties
everybody's like yo you got to walk
around in public with your titties
hanging out and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
granthar says if someone were to break
in in the middle of the night what
caliber would greet them
um [ __ ] i got a choice of them man
[ __ ] 762 39 556.
40 caliber
uh nine um
got 380.
i don't have a 22 but i need to get a 22
kit for my ars there's a [ __ ] drop in
conversion for it i don't know how i've
never had one they used them as training
devices in the navy a long time ago i
think uh atchka atkinson i think or
atchinson was a company that made it a
drop-in kit for the navy
where you could put it in you could
replace the m16 bolt with that 22 long
rifle
and qualify with the m16 while you're at
c
with using a 22.
um and the kit that i've seen for sale
for a couple hundred bucks looks like
like a remake of that same idea
but i don't know how the
the accuracy is i mean you'd get
something like that for varminting you
know just drop it in there shoot rabbits
or something target
i have to look into it i don't know how
accurate they are that would be the key
thing
i suppose so well yeah because a pellet
rifle will [ __ ] do better or you know
for for a lot cheaper
for varmints you know rabbit and
squirrel pellet rifle does it better
kills them faster
i've tried that 22. just blows right
through them pellet rifle [ __ ] kill
them
head shots and stuff well headshots kill
them both but well you're talking we're
talking about like a bunny rabbit
breaking into the house yeah no i'm
talking from varmity
well that wasn't the that wasn't the
question so that was why i was confused
no just come behind okay and when it
went down a rabbit hole
literally this time yeah it went down a
rabbit hole see like sometimes right
yeah a fourth row down says any
intruders would be greeted by tom the
sexual north man
you need to get a dick in your booty
man you got a dick gonna be deep up in a
booty you gotta walk out of here change
man
in touch with your femininity
wearing high heels and [ __ ] g-string
zack will be on the [ __ ] door waiting
for you to come out he's going to be
he's zach is going to be trying to
[ __ ] capitalize on that [ __ ] once i'm
done with you
it's gonna be like something out of a
maximum security penitentiary [ __ ]
leather daddy abuse just [ __ ] [ __ ]
you up well i mean it's gonna be like
something from [ __ ]
like something spartans would do back
[ __ ] back in the day
spartans not only do they kick your ass
and [ __ ] killed you if you
surrendered to them they raped you
you know
that'd be bad
i mean they were raping men
you're like you know because compared to
them you were a woman
that's how [ __ ] macho they were
i mean
well it's interesting that we're talking
about that because yeah
that's that lies behind a lot of yeah
slides yeah kind of thing clyde barrel
and the barrel gang and [ __ ] you know le
it's left out of
kind of like the tv versions of this
story they were bisexuals
clyde well at least according to one guy
who was in the gang like many years
later when he was trying to well the cop
they would have ducked cops in the and
kind of befriend
abducted cops
uh and
you know they they let them go they
didn't really have anything against long
law enforcement they didn't well they
killed enough they killed some of them
but
if you attack them they attack they
counter attack yeah or if they thought
that they were in danger yeah they would
be for sure but uh they abducted at
least one cop that i could think of and
uh he had a good time with him he did he
said they were real nice
and they eventually let him go uh uh but
he he said that um they were both
bisexual
now he didn't say whether or not
they uh uh molested him i guess not i
you know
but clive got into that when he was uh
in prison somebody claims he might have
been like that before but
it was a weird situation it's 1920s man
people [ __ ] don't realize what the
20s were like
are we getting into this subject now
already it's a little early huh i mean
not really but yes well i'll set it up
i'll set it up how about that yeah i
mean i didn't really come across
anything like this uh in my research so
yeah i saw interviews a long time ago
with the guy who is the cop that was
evidently abducted
um he was old when he was given the
interview though and they did the
interview like in the 80s or 90s
um
you know maybe he was lying i don't know
but i saw it on the history channel if i
remember correctly a long time ago
but um
uh what was i getting at
the 1920s were a time
almost kind of like now
in a way
um the world was falling apart
uh
the credibility of the government of
society's institutions was at all time
low at that in the 1920s
um and it was because kind of like the
victorian era was ending it was just
falling apart and
uh corruption in the united states was
[ __ ] horrible
uh everything was kind of like a
form of [ __ ] usury
a lot of robber barons it was kind of
like the worst elements
of centralized ultra powerful capitalism
and it was taking place in the united
states taking place back in europe and
this is all stuff that eventually in
certain countries brought out like the
bolsheviks revolution and everything it
didn't happen that didn't happen in the
united states but it almost did we had
bolshevik communist parties here we had
technocrat parties we just had [ __ ]
got guys that were just anarchists
and kaibaro and [ __ ] a lot of the
motorized bandits of the of the era
were kind of just like
anarchists all right
some of them were
world war one veterans
uh coming back from world war one and
they felt that they had just been
suckered and fighting a war that they
had nothing to do with
uh you know it was the same old deal
mayor the american empire sending guys
overseas to fight for will for a war
they have nothing to do with you know uh
and then they come back and treated
badly and they said [ __ ] it these a lot
of them were just attacking the
institutions
uh they pretty much waged a war against
banks
cops um
they kind of waged a psychological
warfare against the press
but some of them also kind of [ __ ]
had a weird symbiotic relationship with
the press
um
and then they uh kind of had a robin
hood type
um
relationship with the general public
a lot of general public liked them
because they were
kind of
the few brave people to kind of
stand up and sit and and fight against
a system most people thought was corrupt
well the thing about it too was that you
have to think this is like in the midst
of the great depression i mean when uh
bonnie and clyde were in their heyday
and
the reason that they were
kind of romanticized at the time now the
public did turn against them eventually
because their murderous ways kind of got
the better of them
but at first
uh and it wasn't just bonnie and clyde
it was kind of old like pretty boy floyd
and all the kind of like big uh you know
gangsters and stuff is that you know
most people were poor as [ __ ] and not
like poor like nowadays like [ __ ]
poor like homeless no shoes no nothing
no electricity no electricity they were
like living in [ __ ] tents and [ __ ]
like that so where was mississippi
yeah well and the thing about it is that
you know so some in some ways they were
just kind of like yeah these are people
that have taken control of their own
destiny
and they're kind of like [ __ ] on the
big institutions that they kind of like
felt like put them in those situations
and the thing about it too you had to it
wasn't just the great depression there
was also like a massive uh drought in
the midwest which is the dust bowl and
that was kind of like so poverty was
rampant and like i said it was like
[ __ ] poverty yeah and the average
person blamed the institutions for all
this poverty
because they did [ __ ] it up uh wall
street big business
uh corrupt politicians
and then law enforcement which kind of
was protecting them they were all kind
of had a hand in the bad
situation that was created corruption
had a lot to do with it like the great
depression was kind of artificially
produced uh
[ __ ] up wall street practices had a
lot to do with it and then they started
passing laws which made it even worse
i don't remember all the details but i
remember hearing a modern economist
[ __ ] say there was an overreaction
and today that kind of [ __ ] happens all
the time but they know how to then how
to fix it but back in those days
wall street could run amok
and uh government would run amok and try
to over try to overcorrect a problem and
make the problem worse well the thing
about it was that they didn't you have
to think there weren't a lot of laws in
place that are in place now to kind of
prevent certain things from happening
stem from that time period when those
laws were not in place also and they
didn't know
that too that's what i'm saying also
that's what i'm saying wall street and
everything and money markets
and uh what marx would call capitalism
that's what he would call it most people
didn't even understand how it worked it
was just like a
monster running itself
like if you if you read marxist
literature if you i've read analysis of
marxist literature marx has who was
really spoke out against it and i think
in some ways he was right in emotionally
in a certain way
but really marx had no understanding of
economy
you know um he was imagining things that
were happening
uh but the reality was is that it was
just kind of uh
um
what was happening the economy and the
economy was just kind of running on
autopilot it did what it wanted to do
you could you you could kind of manage
it with laws but the average person the
average lawmaker really didn't
understand economy
not by the modern sense of the word
economy
they were also on the gold standard
uh which is kind of like
a steampunk concept now we're not on a
gold standard we're
on a kind of keynesian type
uh
[ __ ] system where you can pull money
out of nowhere it's almost like money
magic
so it'd be kind of like
uh com kind of like comparing steam
power with fusion big difference
um there doesn't have to be a limited
amount of money
you can make as much money as you want
and put it into a system
but people have to have con have to have
confidence in that system if not it just
collapses and falls apart like every
african government tried to do the same
thing all right just like
write up a bunch of money but then
quickly it would just collapse and it
was for a lot of different reasons one
you got to back that money up
usually it's backed up with guns or
ships
you know a navy
you have to have
the will of the the institution printing
this money has to be able to have a will
that can [ __ ] or its will must be
made manifest in other words in other
words it has to have the ability to
punish you if it doesn't have the
ability to punish you the money isn't
worth very much all the rest of the
money is kind of in the world is kind of
leaned up against
the money of the super powers and you're
only a superpower if you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
up you can't [ __ ] [ __ ] up you're not a
super power
um
it's a con j it's a con game though
money is imaginary
it's just like indians making wampum out
of rabbit dung
you take a piece of rabbit [ __ ] put a
hole through it and [ __ ] make some
marks on it and it's money all of a
sudden the indians believed it and it
worked for them because they believed it
it was it was it symbolized trade you
know
the dollar is the same way but you have
to have confidence in it
so it's kind of funny you know
it's fusion now you can make as much
money as you believe can the system can
support and other people don't believe
it and all of a sudden it'll collapse
hyperinflation like what happened in
germany and brazil when i was in brazil
the money hyperinflated one day and i
just saw i thought it was leaves blowing
down the [ __ ] sidewalk it was money
people throwing all their money out
because it was worth nothing
all the money in your bank account went
down to nothing
you have to think too that this this is
a time in american history which like i
said because i know some of our
listeners are not from here but this is
a time when the fbi did not exist yet
actually the fbi kind of came into being
either directly or indirectly because of
this not just because of bonnie and
clyde but because of like people like
that like because of the whole gangster
era because prior to this
you didn't really have a national law
enforcement thing that could kind of
like come in and the thing about it too
was that even things like murder or bank
robbery and [ __ ] like that weren't
federal crimes which is why a lot of
people
would commit a crime in a state then
move the next state over and they'd
never catch you or never do anything
because they didn't really have any
jurisdiction in that uh
for a person say maybe in europe
they might have a heart having a hard
time
envisioning the situation that he exists
to this day in the united states
in our states we have counties
that sometimes are rival the size of a
european country
all right
um if we can our some of our states are
huge like uh [ __ ] texas is twice the
size of germany
the united states was kind of formed out
of a union kind of like the eu
all right kind of like the european
union the federal government was kinda
just a very limited body that ran the
mail and managed the uh
the army
and conducted foreign diplomacy
each state was its own country had its
own police force it had its own legal
system had it ran its own elections to
this day the federal government can't go
into any old state with with its army
and boss to state around a state could
just say no and the
and the federal agents and federal army
cannot come into your state
the state each state is sovereign like a
sovereign country
here's a good way if you're a star trek
fan
washington dc the district of columbia
which is a little neutral zone is
basically the united federation of
planets that's what it is it's the
federation
this each state is like its own planet
but what's weird about the united states
is that it's all have the same it's all
the same language and they're all
watching the same television
they all have the same mass media
so it kind of seems from especially from
the outsider that it's that it's one
country but if you grow up here it's
different regions
and they all have their regional
cultures and
their own dialects and they have their
own past because some states tried to
leave and were forced back in it's been
around for a long time um
the racial makeup of each one of these
states is
different so
when the fbi came in there was a weird
thing that happened that the motorized
bandits
like bonnie and clyde tried to exploit
you could commit
a crime a serious crime like a murder or
a robbery and
and if you could get across state lines
into the state next to it you were
scot-free because that crime was
committed in that state you left the new
state that you're in does not have
jurisdiction over the
ov over the you know over you because
that crime happened over there
yeah that's what i was saying right it's
like you did it in another planet the
weird thing about it though is that i'm
pretty sure i remember reading that even
though murder and bank robbery were not
federal crimes like stealing a car and
taking it across state lines was yeah
well they had certain things
certain laws that involved interstate
theft but they were still trying to work
out a system
yeah
now um
the fbi came out and
it was kind of like the police force
that handled crimes that involved
crossing state lines yeah in other words
it was a way of erasing that gray area
one of the main
thing one of one of the main things it
had to offer is it had a really good
crime lab
um it also had because there were
compacts with these states
they could chase an offender across
state lines when a state cop couldn't do
that a federal cop could
it's still like that
it's still like that
if you
across if you commit a crime in one
state run across the
and then run across the state lines
there there's going to be extradition
packs where that the state you get
arrested in will extradite you back yes
yeah sometimes most the time the feds
don't have to get involved because the
states have worked that out between
themselves yeah it depends what it is if
it's what it is yeah if it's if it's a
big real
high profile crime but you have like
serial killers that go from state to
state [ __ ] like that yeah
so this is all coming out of the early
1900s the average person doesn't travel
very much there isn't an interstate road
system there isn't any highways yet all
that shit's post world war ii
it's dirt roads mostly
they have cars they're on dirt [ __ ]
roads
yeah people realize that don't realize
that these are dirt roads that's why
those cars didn't go that fast
they were well and the and one reason
why clyde swore by the new ford v8 and
every time he stole a car
to you know do some crimes and get away
from the cops he would always steal a
ford v8 because
the cops didn't have v8s yet yeah so he
was like way faster faster and they also
they used very heavy gauge steel um body
parts which could stop
uh 45 automatic rounds so 45 was fired
out of the thompson submachine gun and
government model 1911 45 automatic
pistols
the 45 in the 1911 45 if you ever see it
you'll instantly recognize it some
people call it the gi 45 it's what we
carried in world war one and world war
ii and they're still popular today here
in the united states they were kind of
like the desert eagle of the [ __ ]
early 1900s they were a big
handsome looking very simple pistol
fired a big old [ __ ] slow bullet
known as the
45 1911 round it's 230 grain bullet
moving at about 830 feet a sec or 800
feet a second around there usually
if i remember correct they might have
been 8 20.
um with just a big heavy ball moving
slow
if you're firing a fire in a uh that
also is fired out of the tops of
submachine guns
a car body a heavy car body could stop
that at a distance
here's something else you could do the
45 is funny
uh with the with with the thompson
submachine gun on full auto if you got
your head down behind the barrel and you
let off a blast and you can see past the
smoke you can actually see the line
of [ __ ] rounds going through the air
very vaguely
they're so big you can see them going
down range if the if the lighting's the
lighting conditions are right
like it's kind of a [ __ ] funny thing
about them uh most most
most uh firearms you can't do that
because they're just slow and they're
big
but they do a lot of damage and they
don't have to [ __ ] expand like a
hollow point to do damage they did
pretty good damage
they weren't very good at armor
penetration though later on the guy who
made that was uh john moses browning
designed the 1911
improved it to the [ __ ] browning high
power which is 19 which was nine
millimeter and carried i think 13 rounds
12 13 rounds in a magazine and that was
the one you saw axel foley carrying in
beverly hills cop classic pistol
some countries still use it
similar to the 1911.
but um
so this is the world that bonnie and
clyde are coming out of
and here's another thing that was
happening during this era a lot of
people don't realize it
because the institutions were basically
rotten
and society was breaking down people
realize people started to figure there
really weren't any rules
because there wasn't any way to enforce
rules to speak of
and one of the things that they stopped
enforcing
was sexual morality rules so there was a
there was a a sexual revolution in in
the 1920s
um but you had to look for it you had to
go to speakeasies and you had to go to
good night clubs and you had to hang out
with
cool people and you'd find a lot of what
they call like free love and
um homosexuality bisexuality pad
sexuality
um
they'd have
polyamory
all the all the [ __ ] that they could
give a fancy name for today they were
doing that back in the 1920s they just
didn't really have a name for it
oh they didn't categorize what they did
and then in all these cool places you
had organized criminals of various types
including italian mob
and those were like the cool guys they
were kind of like the
they were i guess you could say they're
kind of like the goths or the punk
rockers of their era
and they were involved in all this
they were not sexually uptight
um
it would have been an interesting time
although i don't think the hygiene was
that good
yeah that's what i'm saying it's like
yeah it might be interesting to like go
back to you for like a couple days or
something but yeah i wouldn't want to
like go back and live there no thanks
nah the music wasn't very good uh they
were listening to radio and radio
quality the radio went that good uh
they uh
had no problem with anybody being
underage uh it didn't seem to be a big
deal to pick up [ __ ] 11 12 year old
girls and screw them they just as long
as they didn't have parents that were
watching out on but it's just a weird
time and they kind of felt that they
were in the apocalypse i believe
uh but then later on things changed
world war ii changed everything
that was the beginning of the modern era
and in a way it got better but in other
ways it got worse because [ __ ] power
centralized
as power centralized there's always
going to be abuses
uh lesson from this what we're going to
learn today is that you can't trust a
[ __ ] humans are
humans are basically evil monkeys hair
evil hairless monkeys they're they have
always been evil hairless monkeys
they will always be evil hairless
monkeys
no matter what their station in life and
the government will always kind of
[ __ ] abuse you
it's been going on for thousands of
years
take care of yourself first make your
own decisions and live your own life
don't sign away your life to people
because they can't [ __ ] solve your
problems you got to take care of
yourself and the people you care about
uh but this is we're gonna get into the
story about [ __ ] bonnie and clyde
they were an interesting couple
uh poor choices though but they were
young
they were young yeah i think people
forget like how young they actually were
they were like in their early 20s yeah
real young poor chances
um now the thing about
um bonnie
the photos most of the photos that
that have survived her body she looks
like very skinny
old lady really is what she looks like
and some with her posing with guns and
stuff
i saw one really good pictures over
she's [ __ ] gorgeous she's really cute
yeah she is really cute
and i think there's only like one or two
good pictures of her where she's real
cute most of the pictures that survive
over came out of the newspaper and the
the gra the the resolutions real low and
they're not not real flattering pictures
of her she's just a cute
little
chick she's probably
4 10
maybe 85 pounds a little bitty thing
and uh the people that knew her like the
cops that they abducted said she had a
bubble bubbly and very delightful
personality and nothing at all like you
see
in newspaper pictures over
but
well the the very uh iconic pictures of
her like the one with uh the cigar like
where she has the cigar and the pistol
and stuff and the one where she's kind
of like jokingly like pointing the gun
at
uh clyde
is those were actually just pictures
that she took or that they took like
just for fun
and they ended up being found by cops
later on because they got left behind
like during a shootout or something like
that and then the cops or whatever and
then the media ended up getting them so
they didn't really intend like for the
media to see that but interestingly i
kind of feel like if those photos hadn't
been published i'm not saying that
bonnie and clyde wouldn't have been as
famous like i don't know maybe they
wouldn't have been quite as famous they
still might have been famous
but
i think those pictures really sealed it
because i mean they kind of said
in particular that one picture of bonnie
with the cigar people were really like
think about that cigar because women
didn't do that didn't smoke cigars yeah
and apparently she said later she even
like told like them later slick i don't
smoke cigars i just did that for the
picture or whatever um and then there
were even like some conspiracy theories
that it was actually like not a cigar in
her mouth it was like something else and
it got it got changed but yeah but so
but it became like a big deal which is
hilarious nowadays because i don't think
anybody would care if a woman was
smoking a cigar but back in the 1930s
early 1930s yeah it was like a big big
deal she was just clowning around she
was a little bitty skinny pretty
waitress that clive met and picked her
up
and they became friends
now these were i want to before the show
starts i want to stress that these two
are not random
low-skilled [ __ ] that just pick
up guns and then go out and do crazy
[ __ ] that's not what happened here
clive was a professional criminal he was
a professional robber they trained for
this they even did firearms training
fire they would buy the the best weapons
available
had a modified by really good gunsmiths
especially clive's bar
they had carrying equipment for their
ammunition and they did fire fire on the
move live fire training
during their their little travels
they didn't do this [ __ ] randomly they
were good they were really good and so
and so was
so was bonnie bonnie evidently could
fire a bar from the hip
while she was carrying money fire and
she only weighed like 85 pounds
have a bag of money a [ __ ] bar or a
strap on the other on on the other arm
be at a full run and fire from the hip
and hit a [ __ ] cop about a i think 75
meters i think 50 to 75 meters away and
be able to hit him why she was running
he was moving
so they were good they were really good
and it's because they they trained
they
approached this as if it was a business
it wasn't just some spur of the moment
thing
and they trained on the move
they'd stop the car and they'd [ __ ]
buy a weapon they'd buy [ __ ]
ammunition and go pick up modified
weapons and then they'd
well they sold a lot of weapons from
armories and [ __ ] yeah but they would
also but they take they would take clive
took that bar and had it modified by a
gunsmith and went back and got he had it
shortened a lot
and then they went out and practiced
with them they were good they were good
real good
and this is in a time when the average
cop
was about like a mall security guard
that was the level of the of the average
cop they didn't train at all yeah they
weren't real
i mean it was like i said it was during
the great depression a little bit after
the great depression and these were
mostly rural rural areas areas
and this is uh this is what part of the
reason why they needed the fbi
it was because the state of the s
the state of local cops was terrible
they were just like
like like i said a mall security guard
with a 38 special revolver imagine that
that was the level you're at overweight
didn't underpaid these dudes didn't want
to risk their lives for a [ __ ]
a job that paid next to nothing and had
no benefits
so the cops for the most part weren't a
problem as court according to the
bandits of the era
um
they didn't pay him anything you know
and uh
sometimes a [ __ ] robber would share
loot with a [ __ ] cop here man i know
they're not paying anything here they
give him a stack of money run
that's that was the state of the world
which seems like a wise move back in
those days that that's what i would have
done had i had a criminal nobody cared
about that
now
because america has a much higher
population density now in most areas now
well actually everywhere so it's higher
there's a lot more people here now
so uh
local police are far better trained in
this area era than they ever were
in in
in the area we're talking about in the
1920s a local cop of today you know in
just a random
county around here would be is like
special forces compared to the average
[ __ ] beat cop of the 1920s yeah i
mean back then like you said they had no
special training at all i mean you have
to think this is
1920s early 1930s they don't have any
forensic science really to speak of no
radios they don't have any radios they
don't have anything like that these are
just guys that needed a job and they're
just like okay fine and you know that's
that's all they had they were they were
under gunned they didn't have you know
the cars a lot of times they had to use
their own vehicles yeah they didn't
really have like police cars catching a
bad guy really didn't give you much
didn't do much for you
yeah i mean it didn't give you a pay
increase
and you're putting your life on the
[ __ ] line for somebody else's
property usually
so why would you get killed for
trying to save a rich man's [ __ ] wad
of cash that you had nothing to do with
it you just let that [ __ ] go
yeah that's that's kind of how i would
feel about it too i'm just like why the
[ __ ] i want to get shot over like a bank
getting but they're they're insured i
assume yeah so
so the police themselves were already
demoralized most people were demoralized
in this era
which if they say we're headed for an
economic town turn right now and if
[ __ ] it goes this way again with the
population density you have now it's
going to not gonna be pretty
and they're not an army in the world
that can stop it
i was in the us army [ __ ] four years
and [ __ ] contracted for another
[ __ ]
four years
six seven eight years after that a
little piece meal [ __ ] here and that
[ __ ] the us army is not in any shape
it could barely handle afghanistan what
makes you think hey it could handle
something the size of the continental
united states you got the police forces
that can maybe keep it on but i i saw
katrina happen
and that was like going back to the
[ __ ] dark ages man
that was bizarre i was in baton rouge at
the time would that happen but in
support of the [ __ ] state police of
the [ __ ] louisiana state police
and
the company i worked for helped them
and it was like
the only reason
had that happened
in a european country
in a small european country that that
little european country would have
written about how their you know the
the time that their civilization
collapsed for [ __ ] three three months
and it probably wouldn't have recovered
the only reason why that area recovered
is because it was just a localized area
and there was an outside areas were all
stable so they jumped in there and
[ __ ] put it back together if that had
happened in a small country that country
be through
it was [ __ ] wild man it was wild it
was the apocalypse
murder hornet return says super chats to
get tom to dance the charleston
now i'm going to dance that [ __ ] you
don't even know how to yeah just be no i
can't do that
i i kind of know how it goes but i i
can't lean forward and kick your [ __ ]
legs
slash afraid that there was a folk song
called the ballad of bonnie and clyde
yeah i think there was and actually i'm
not really sure if that version is what
i'm thinking of but one of them had the
lyrics were actually written by bonnie
because she was uh
she was a poet actually and she wrote a
lot of poems and they uh did do like a
song version of her uh
of her one of her poems that she wrote
actually before i think before she met
clyde but it ended up being like weirdly
prophetic
so they used it as a as a song ballad of
binding glide
bundy data says killing the mob has a
good chapter on them her hip was
deformed and he carried her some
uh but they uh yeah that happened uh
later like while they were on the run
like how that like why he had to carry
her around which was yeah and and uh
murder hornets uh [ __ ] mentioned that
nowadays
state cops can cross the state line if
they're in a hot pursuit of somebody
yeah they like i said over the years
they had all these interstate compacts
started to to form
so we're yeah you can do that now but
although i guarantee you
that's part of some compact and it could
be that
that may not exist between all states i
don't know may probably huh
probably not i've never heard of it not
existing between
state to another right i mean imagine
we're all like no i watch a lot of true
crime [ __ ] and sirens
yeah speaking of crime they're looking
at you they're looking for you
what did i do no murder harness they're
looking for you
oh i don't know what you're doing but
yeah that's i mean i never i watch a lot
of true crime [ __ ] and i never heard of
like something going hey somebody
committed a crime in i don't know
missouri and
you know just wisconsin said no we're
not sending them back that's that never
happens so i'm pretty sure that like
whatever
crime you commit in like whatever state
they're gonna like uh figure it out hugo
says like your wig jenny thank you
yeah i think this is of the three that i
bought i think this is my favorite one i
bought a white one today like this like
similar cut but it's white so we'll see
how that looks i've never had a white
wig before
my hair has been blonde before like
white blonde because i bleached it
before i dyed it red
um and it looked okay but i don't know
what the white's gonna look like but
whatever they're not that expensive so i
figured why not i wanted a purple one
but they didn't have one they had
lavender but that was about it
so oh speaking of gangsters we talked
about this on
yesterday's matinee show but i like to
uh you know talk about it on the main
show
so
our friend louie friend of the show
who's always sending us kick ass movies
yesterday sent us
the godfather trilogy
the blu-ray 50th anniversary and i'm
very very excited about this because
it's probably been
at least 20 years
since i've seen
the godfather and uh so i'm looking
forward to like watching the whole
trilogy and we'll probably do matinees
on them you know sunday monday tuesday
so that'll be really good so thank you
louie i just i don't think he's here
because i don't see him in the chat but
if you are or if you're listening later
thank you very much you always send us
good movies and uh we just really
appreciate it
uh bundy data said hoover wanted to get
the robbers he denied organized crime
and killers getting the robbers made a
name for him he denied there was a casa
nostra yeah it's just kind of like i
don't know i do kind of feel like uh j
edgar hoover was sort of involved in
this whole
establishing of the fbi thing well like
i said it was a good idea and it's
really funny because
i mean 1931
or 1934 when you know bonnie and clyde
got killed
uh you know that wasn't really it was a
long time ago but it wasn't that long
ago you know what i'm saying like my
grandparents were alive at that time so
you know that's not that long ago so
it's crazy to think that like the fbi
didn't even exist then like they didn't
even like think of it
and so
that's what i'm saying like you know all
the crimes that i wrote about like in
some of my books that happened like
prior to
you know the 1930s
it's really interesting how easy it was
to get away with [ __ ] like even horrible
murders and [ __ ] like that because like
i said all you had to do was like cross
the state line and to be honest i think
that clyde
barrow
knew that
you know obviously the criminals at the
time knew that if you cross the state
line you know you were kind of like
scot-free
so they would kind of like maneuver
things like the way that they
went around the country like so they
were going over state lines all the time
so that you know so they would weave
through yeah they would kind of like
weave in and out because they absolutely
knew that hey it was like easier to keep
from getting caught they were smart
yeah i mean he absolutely knew what he
was doing yeah that's for sure he also
knew where all the
border area banks were if you were
nowhere near a state border they were
gonna rob from you you had to be in a
border bank
and the thing about their about them
being known as like bank robbers they
did rob some banks but they were usually
like rural banks they weren't usually
like no big [ __ ] banks and they
mostly robbed other [ __ ] like they
usually robbed like
kind of like hardware stores just
regular stores funeral parlors that kind
of [ __ ] more stuff that was like low
key i guess they did rob some banks but
they weren't usually like big yeah it
was low-risk stuff out here i don't know
where it would be a
you know if you
[ __ ] growing up during all the summers
in heidelberg mississippi population
[ __ ] 800 out in mississippi
you could imagine what it was like back
in the 20s because that's that's a town
back then was maybe 500 300.
a couple could just go in there and
[ __ ] just run them up quickly and
then scoot out
in an era when most people didn't have
cars
yeah and there was no
radio so the cops might know but there's
no way they could radio to anybody else
yeah you were kind of hosed i mean
you're your host yeah
it's kind of like the old west
same type of situation which like i said
i you know i was saying while you were
in the bathroom it's like yeah in 1934
when they got killed that was a long
time ago but not really that i mean my
grandparents were alive yeah at that
time my grandparents were
well my grandmother would have been
five or six and my grandfather would
have been in his teens six years later
we were entering in world war
two
six years later he'd be going into world
war two with [ __ ] big ass four engine
bombers and [ __ ] tanks and machine
guns you know i mean
and uh the modern united states is
starting to form with a
military-industrial complex starting to
merge up where america is becoming a
[ __ ] corporate empire you know
just a few years after this
murder hornet says seeing pics of that
car if you was in that car anywhere you
ain't living yeah um that's kind of like
the very definition of overkill
that car was [ __ ] riddled with
bullets it just looks like overkill
because you had never been involved in
an ambush all right that's what you do
frank hammer and his buddies got online
and they all had [ __ ] guns a lot of
them were [ __ ] 30 odd 6 bars and full
auto stuff and just a few seconds of
everybody firing that's what happens but
they weren't taking any chances
well he even said that though
they were good that's how good they were
they were good real good bunny dana
young and spry and they were kind of
kamikaze they were suicidal they didn't
care if they lived or died so
if you shot at them or try to apprehend
them they just go run straight at you
[ __ ] in a team
going full auto on you with their
weapons and [ __ ] they were they were
good they were good you didn't want to
[ __ ] go into
armed combat with them
and you know you're
but you know this is law enforcement
they're forced to
you have to so
frank haber was and we haven't gotten
him yet frank hammer's like we're going
to [ __ ] ambush him and it's just a
classic ambush
it's classy ambush
i did ambush and counter ambush training
[ __ ] my whole time in the military
just like that
that's the way to do it it's never fair
it's
set in a trap they come in
kill them
don't even know it's coming
it's the easiest way to do it
you don't take any any you don't take
any damn casualties which means you can
do it over and over and over again
you don't lose any of your team
that's what it did
yeah i mean there aren't just pictures
of the car there are actually pictures
if you look because i've seen a couple
documentaries of the bodies still in the
car because and there's video of it too
they actually took video of it and bunny
data points out and i'm glad you brought
this up because i remember
uh seeing the car in person
and he said it used to be in saint
augustine the old beat up car like their
death car and i was like okay well that
must have been where i started at the
ripley's museum because i remember
seeing that car
as a kid so it must have been in the
ripley's in saint augustine because i
went there many times as a child
so yeah i did see the actual death car
and yeah that [ __ ] was like riddled with
bullets actually uh and i know we're
like jumping the gun on this stuff but
they're i guess the guy that was doing
uh
was embalming them was upset because
it's like their bodies are so full of
bullet holes that the embalming fluid
was like leaking out and he was like
getting upset about it so yeah many many
many many bullet holes yeah in the car
and in the bodies
when we get into this you guys can
[ __ ] scroll over get on your little
laptops or whatever
and look at clyde barrow and [ __ ]
bonnie
these are
not big people i think i think [ __ ]
clyde might have he's probably my size
five six
five five maybe something like that and
bonnie is
maybe four eleven five two row two in
that period these are
little people
and they weren't as little for their era
but by today's standards they'd be
little
and um
fierce fierce little [ __ ] you know
and friendly
if you're face to face with them but
if you shot at them or gave them any
[ __ ] they'd kill you
well their whole thing and particularly
clyde and i think that just because
bonnie was so in love with him that she
went along with it too they they pretty
much knew that they were going to get
killed doing this i don't think they had
an illusion
about it yeah and clyde in particular um
for reasons we'll get into later was
basically like i am not being taken
alive yeah he didn't want to go by
prison so yeah and like i said we'll get
into why later on but it's like yeah so
he just basically said i'm not being
taken alive so if any cops come to try
to arrest me i'm gonna be able to shoot
him or you know like i said they were
pretty
they seemed pretty like circumspect
about you know we're gonna get killed
doing this one day yeah it was they
didn't it's not like a kamikaze suicide
pact
they they weren't gonna amount to
anything in life
especially clyde
uh bonnie she was a waitress she had an
honest job
but she was a country girl and in that
era she probably thought she'd never
really amount to anything
and he and he offered an adventurous
lifestyle
and money out of nowhere she'd probably
never seen [ __ ] 20 bill yeah probably
not they both grew up unbelievably poor
right clyde more so than bonnie but
bonnie was pretty [ __ ] poor too so
they kind of saw the [ __ ] world is
falling apart it's like the apocalypse
and they got nothing to lose so they're
going to go out with a blaze of glory
they're going to go steal money until
people kill them
and they're going to fight until the
until the day
and they did they reckon incumbent i
mean absolutely and i mean they got
[ __ ] up i mean they got shot they got
injured they got all all kind of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] happened so it wasn't just like
oh they got killed in an ambush they did
but they had been
wounded many times prior to that also
sad side of it is had they chilled the
[ __ ] out and waited maybe another 10 15
years the situation the united states
started to change for a better
they probably wouldn't probably would
have ended up living normal lives and
living a lot longer but what did they
know they were [ __ ] kids you know
yeah i mean when you think about it and
like i said i don't want to because i do
kind of feel like bonnie and clyde and
we talked about this when we talked
about ned kelly last week i do kind of
feel like criminals like this that come
out in a certain era
are like romanticized
and bonnie and clyde have been
romanticized big time i mean and i think
they were romanticized at the time
although like i said the more the
murders started to stack up like the
more the public turned against them but
when the movie came out with warren
beatty and faye dunaway in 1967
i kind of feel like people like
romanticized them all over again because
it made it look kind of glamorous even
though you know the surviving members of
the gang are people that were around
back then that knew what was going on
were like it was absolutely not
glamorous no you know what i mean but
you know it was different but in the
movie so i kind of feel like people saw
it as like a [ __ ] up like romeo and
juliet yeah type story which that's not
what it really was not really thank you
janet thanks jen
i love the i love the little pair well
thanks for being you it says the thing
that was left out of a lot of the old
movies was the sexual angle
okay
the body was kind of in heaven in a way
because she was with the guys she liked
he was cute adventurous kind of [ __ ]
swashbuckling [ __ ] bandit who was
[ __ ] had all this cash
and they'd go out and pick up guys and
have sex with guys
so she was kind and a constant [ __ ]
threesome with [ __ ] high guys
so
that was part of the angle that was left
out a lot
but
i think that's part of the reason i
think she loved him but i think she also
loved that lifestyle
well
and that would be that was very unusual
for the 1920s of course
very unusual for this her thing i think
because honestly you know when she was
growing up she seemed like a normal
girl i mean she was smart and like she
had her [ __ ] together
but
she also like i said she grew up really
poor and i kind of feel like she was
like frustrated because she wanted to
be a movie star i mean she wanted to
like be somebody and i kind of feel like
you know when you grow up poor you kind
of feel like
most of the time that shit's not gonna
happen for you because you don't have
opportunities the same way that somebody
with money would have opportunities you
know what i'm saying and it's very
frustrating so i can see how
i'm not saying she didn't love clyde she
did
clearly i mean they both loved each
other like
crazily yeah and this put her in the
[ __ ] spotlight too yeah national
spotlight so
she went out doing what she liked to do
yeah
unwise
she could have lived longer but you
never know well like you said they were
kids they were kids yeah
and honestly i hate to say it but it's
like she wanted to be famous she is you
got it
yeah they're both famous they knew they
were gonna die so they had that [ __ ]
they had that [ __ ] um
warrior gestalt of [ __ ] uh uh uh
what's his name [ __ ] minamoto musashi
you know [ __ ] shin musashi
said that you can do whatever you want
as long as you're willing to give your
own life for it you know what i mean it
says but you you can't run around
handing out death to other people and
then [ __ ] and moan like a [ __ ] when
somebody comes and hands death out to
you
all right it's a two-way street and
that's kind of at least they [ __ ]
at least they embrace the philosophy of
[ __ ] musashi if you're gonna go out
and do that [ __ ] you better expect to
die live by the sword you die by the
sword that's how that's and they
everything that i've read about them
they absolutely did expect like they
obviously tried to avoid it yeah but
they had to live as long as they could
they tried to live as long as they could
but they pretty much knew that that's
how the end was going to come well
that's what [ __ ] musashi says that
the [ __ ] warrior's life is the
resolute acceptance of death
you must accept that you will die
and
that's what it was
yeah i did it when i [ __ ] went to my
first war i figured out i'll probably
die but i'ma have fun
and it's the it's the psychology of a 20
year old very much so
and as i said you have to remember that
during their spree
yeah they were both in their early 20s
yeah early 20s i know the mindset yeah
so
not excusing it like i said they knew
what they were doing was bad but young
and dumb and full of calm yeah that's
pretty much yeah pretty much but musashi
lived i think to his 50s though lived a
long time had a [ __ ] long trail of
[ __ ] victories behind him
i'm going to do a show on musashi
musashi well right like write that [ __ ]
down well i don't know where my because
we are into all these [ __ ] criminals
and serial killers and [ __ ] there are
guys that kind of tread the and
and
shred the [ __ ] boundaries
musashi [ __ ] who is a great japanese
national hero
they had censored a lot of his writings
but
um was was a person like this
he had even a weird more tumultuous
childhood and everything though but one
of the greatest [ __ ] yakuza samurais
of all times which i kind of put him
even more like a more like an outlaw
mercenary
samurai looked up to him they came later
yeah i didn't realize this but a couple
years back 2019
netflix actually did a
a movie called the highwayman which is
actually about bonnie and clyde but from
the law enforcement point of view like
so it follows like the
the law guys that like we're chasing
them and stuff so i don't know we'll
have to watch that one of these days but
yeah there have been like [ __ ] tons
of movies and
documentaries and songs and musicals and
jesus christ so much stuff so like i
said i know she's not around to
appreciate it but maybe bonnie would
appreciate it that
that she is absolutely famous nowadays
even nowadays people still know and like
i said they're making movies they don't
make movies just about them they make
these are like that are like [ __ ]
based on them you know what i mean like
loosely like uh what was the one with uh
somebody mentioned it earlier on in the
comments with uh woody harrelson and
what's face what's that what's that
uh natural born killers
that's kind of based on janet's asking
questions about their sexuality and [ __ ]
there
uh yeah janet said i read a book where
he wasn't that into her sexually so i
just wondered i don't know i was yeah i
kind of feel like they were i mean they
were pretty um inseparable witnesses
said that he [ __ ] loved her he was
sucking in love but uh but they were i
think they were both bisexual
both of them but i think uh
i think um
clive barrow was a true bisexual he was
into guys too all right i think um
i i think
you know i think they if from her
correctly they did have some
some troubles with with females but that
really
that really wasn't um
bonnie's thing she was more into like
threesomes with other guys
which she was heterosexual lovely
but no club was climbed by
mrs evans already party said i freaking
love the highwaymen so good yeah i'm
gonna have to watch that i meant to like
watch it before we did this but i didn't
have time to watch it but i just found
out about it like a few days ago you
know what i mean
uh mike barrett says how many theatrical
films were made of bonnie and clyde i
only just the 60s one is the most famous
but
i don't know i kind of feel like there
were a couple other ones but some of the
ones were like loosely based on them
like i said like natural-born killers
and [ __ ] like that but you know i can't
i don't have a list but there were a lot
or it's mostly like documentaries i
looked on youtube
and
there's like
a zillion documentaries about them from
like tons of different yeah from like
tons of different things okay
so uh all right so let's talk a little
bit about
um
okay so i thanked louis for the
godfather movies yes i did all right so
let's talk about uh bonnie as a kid
so she's born in 1910 uh in a place
called rowena
texas
now her dad was a bricklayer
but he died when she was four
now obviously because this is 1910 um
you know her mom's a widow now they
don't have any [ __ ] money
so
she moves the family which was uh
bonnie was like the second kid she and
eventually like her mom had three kids
but they go back to her parents house
which is in a place called cement city
which is in west dallas and it was
essentially
a slum
um the mom got a job as a seamstress but
like i said this wasn't
she didn't live in as abject poverty as
clyde did
but
she was still pretty [ __ ] poor they
lived in essentially islam in west allis
now uh bonnie did go to school for a
little while
up until she was in her teens uh and was
an honor student apparently uh
was really like uh liked and she was
really into poetry and [ __ ] like that
and as i mentioned earlier really wanted
to be a movie star or she she was really
into photography she really wanted to
like make something of herself
now
her second year of high school
she meets this guy
named roy thornton
now
they both dropped out of school
in 1926
and got married
now when they got married bonnie was
almost 16 like she was a little bit uh
less than a week shy of her 16th
birthday so they got married
um which like i said not that weird back
then i guess like nowadays it'd be like
what the [ __ ] but yeah back then weird
but not that weird
so uh so she marries this guy maybe she
wanted to like escape the slum i'm not
really sure like why she did or maybe
she was just like you know just in love
with the guy i don't know
but so they get married uh but the
problem was that
her husband
was
reportedly
abusive um also he was gone a lot
and he was like kind of a low-level
criminal like he was always kind of
getting in trouble with the law [ __ ]
like that which maybe she was attracted
by that like why she ended up with clad
later on
uh so they weren't actually well i was
gonna say they weren't married a long
time but technically she was still
married to him when she died uh because
they never legally got divorced but they
did like break up
so uh so she was like left
and
he didn't really like they didn't see
each other again until
after like sometime in like 1929.
interestingly though she still had his
wedding ring on like when she got killed
like later on in 1934
interestingly too
uh when
he when she got killed in the ambush
when her and clyde got killed and they
asked
uh you know they found out that she had
been married to this guy and he was in
prison for something else like
subsequently so the press like asked him
about how he felt about her dying
and his quote was i'm glad they jumped
out like they did it's much better than
being caught that's what he said
oh i've got my drink so he had uh he was
actually sentenced to five years uh in
1933 for robbery
and he kept like trying to bust out of
prison uh and while he was trying to
escape from the huntsville state prison
in 1937 uh he was actually killed who
was this then this was bonnie's husband
oh okay bonnie's husband who she married
when she was almost 16.
uh yeah so there's that guy but that was
after the whole
bonnie and clyde thing no before well
when they get when did they die 1934 34
okay yeah they started in the 20s though
right it wasn't no it wasn't they
started in 1931 31 okay i thought it was
late 20s okay
no she married in 1926 okay right before
like a week before she turned 16. all
right
and then yeah i wasn't sure the exact
dates i always thought it was 20s when
it started like very late 20s 28 29 but
no i guess it was 1930s 30s 1931.
um although it was still basically kind
of like it's roaring 20s but
the depression had hit why are you like
leaning out of the frame oh no over here
so it was still kind of like the 20s but
the depression had hit
by that time yeah well the depression
started in 1929 yeah
so but yeah this was before that
um
but yeah her so her husband who like i
said she never technically divorced
but they didn't see each other after
1929
and um
he got killed like uh during a prison
break because he was kind of criminal
too like kind of low level criminal
uh so after her and her husband kind of
like separated she moved back in with
her mom and she got a job as a waitress
in dallas
interestingly this is another fun fact
with the restaurant that she worked at
one of the customers that would come in
there all the time
was a guy who worked for the post office
whose name was ted hinton
and later on that guy joined the
sheriff's department and was actually
ended up being one of the posse that
ended up killing her
isn't that crazy it's a small world
uh so yeah
now when uh
when bonnie was about 18 years old uh
she started keeping a diary this was
1929 talking about how
you know life in dallas because like i
said she lived in a slum she was just a
waitress it's like she wanted bigger
things out of life and it just
life wasn't going the way she thought it
was going to go
so she kind of like started talking
about that how lonely she was like i
said she was really into photography and
[ __ ] like that too
so now let's talk about clyde i'm gonna
hope that i don't like start
coughing
because my cold went away but no it's
kind of bad now no it will
sometimes if i have a cold
and then it goes away and i feel fine
but every now and then i get like a dry
hack that the like and i start having
coughing kids
for like a week or two afterwards
so clyde
uh clyde chestnut barrow his middle
name's chestnut that's weird
that is kind of weird i've never heard
of that yeah that's his middle name yeah
what a weird what a weird i've never
heard that before i have never heard
that either it almost sounds like a
nickname like it should be an air quote
but it's not it's not that's his name
never heard that so he was born in 1909
so he's a year older than bonnie
and he was actually born into a farming
family uh also in texas like in a little
place like uh southeast of dallas and
pretty much everyone was
in that era every farming family yeah
pretty much
now his parents had seven kids uh of
which clyde was the fifth
now
when we talked about the dust bowl
earlier there had been like a really bad
drought so a lot of farming families
were kind of like losing their [ __ ]
losing their [ __ ] because
you know no crops
yeah because no crops
and that's essentially what happened to
uh the baro family
now they ended up moving so a lot of
people moved into the city like looking
for work so they moved to dallas um you
know along with a lot of other families
like in the early
1920s now uh
they moved to islam and at first they
were
homeless
for the first few months that they moved
to after they moved to dallas they were
essentially living under their wagon
uh for a while
and then they were really excited when
they finally like scraped up enough
money to buy a tent that they could live
in so like i said this is abject poverty
we're talking about there's a whole
family that's basically living in the
street like living in a tent like a lot
of other families worth time because
like i said it's the [ __ ]
it's just like a bad situation all
around
now uh so clyde seemed like
uh kind i don't want to say he seemed
like a criminal from a young age
but
growing up in those circumstances i mean
you're gonna see like
they don't really see like they have any
other option in life i guess he's
fighting back
yeah yeah i mean you know he doesn't
want to be a poor nobody yeah i mean who
does that's what i mean yeah it's not
fun because it's not fun some people are
like oh [ __ ] it there's resides to it
but some people aren't
there was something about the organized
criminals of the [ __ ] early 1900s
this even goes into them
italian mafia
part of what made the italian mob good
is that under normal circumstances they
wouldn't have been criminals they would
have just been normal guys conducting
[ __ ] normal business
they were kind of forced into
criminality because of a [ __ ] shitty
economy
so that meant
your average
organized criminal was a pretty good
quality
compared to compared to today there were
no there were no other options
you know you either accepted your place
or you did something
to [ __ ] get out of it
well like i said i kind of feel like
that's why at first like the public
responded so positively to bonnie and
clyde not just because it was ooh
romantic because it's like a couple but
also because hey they actually like took
the reins of their own life which a lot
of people couldn't do back then because
they were so poor yeah when
when when economies get really bad
depression recession errors for a long
period of time
you got good people resorting to crime
it's uh criminals get better
because they normally wouldn't be a
criminal they're forced into it yeah you
know so they're kind of being drafted
you know
yeah
that's not me saying this i [ __ ] read
a book about it
you see you have high iq people [ __ ]
being forced into crime and they're good
at it and they ended up [ __ ] being
famous for it
mrs evans already party says bet
chestnut was his mother's maiden name
that was common oh yeah i didn't think
about that
that probably was yeah because they did
do that a lot back then
um
somebody said oh do do do do
somebody said that bonnie's uh oh this
was also mrs evans already part he said
i think bonnie's photos are in the moma
yeah that's museum of modern art that's
in new york city
uh which they very well may be i've been
there like a couple of times i don't
remember seeing them but that might not
be like on permanent display most of the
ones i saw came out of the newspaper
they look like [ __ ] but then i saw some
other ones where it was like there were
photos over she's she's cute
real cute
yeah there are a couple of photos of her
uh there i saw a couple of photos of her
with her first husband
um i saw kind of like a glamour shot of
her where it looks like she has false
lashes on and she looks like a movie
star yeah i think that's what i saw like
a glamour shot yeah yeah um and then
there are kind of the famous ones like i
said the famous ones they took like
while they were on the run and those
were just like in a camera that got left
behind so there was that
so uh clyde his first arrest was when he
was 17 years old in late 1926.
now what happened with it it's
a lot of people say oh it's stealing
cars or car theft it wasn't exactly car
theft it was he rented a car
and then he didn't bring it back yeah so
so the um so the rental company was like
hey he stole the car so it wasn't kind
of like he carjacked he was just running
a car and just didn't bring it back so
they just called it that that's kind of
theft it is theft it is technically i'm
just saying it's not probably what
you're thinking of where he just like
broke into a car and stole it but like
it's it was that so that was his first
arrest he was only 17 years old
he got arrested a second time
with his older brother buck who would
later become part of the baro gang
and that was for possessing stolen
turkeys like they were trying to resell
some turkeys they had stolen
now from 1926 to
1929 when he was like late teens early
20s
um he did actually have some legitimate
jobs like he was he seemed like he was
trying to like
have a normal life i guess
but he also had like some criminal [ __ ]
going on on the side you know what i
mean he would also like kind of rob some
stores steal some cars
you know
break into some safes [ __ ] like that
like petty [ __ ]
doing that kind of stuff
now these two bonnie and clyde met each
other um
well there are a lot of different
stories about how they met each other
but the most
the one that has the most credibility i
guess
says that they met
in january of 1930
and it was at the house of a friend of
clyde's whose name was clarence clay and
this is the
of photo you're taught you have to talk
enough no okay that's not it
that's her as a kid yeah i'm guessing
that's actually one of the good photos
of her
yeah she was a cute girl yeah no the one
i the one i'm talking about was like i
said it was like a glamour shot it was
almost kind of like blurry around the
edges and she had like really big
eyelashes and she was kind of looking up
like that that wasn't it either
she's like what the hell
she's mugging up for the camera
she's like what the [ __ ] she doesn't
want her picture yeah
there
that's more
oh yeah i never saw that one actually
so she she's cute
that's right i mean i have to say that
it probably helped as far as their fame
went the both of them were really
good-looking yeah
you know yeah they're yeah cute
because if they'd been
like ugly or old or you would have
forgotten about that or something
a sensation yeah yeah i kind of feel
like seeing the photographs and it's
like some people were like sophie was
like look look at this tiny little girl
and she's got like a cigar and a gun and
she's like shooting cops and [ __ ] like
that and people were like enchanted yeah
you know what i mean i kind of feel like
if she was just like an ugly old bat
everybody like
yeah you know
they're like how'd this happen society
was falling apart
it's it's bound to happen you have
millions of people people are always one
of them
i mean the thing about it is that
whether it's a criminal or whether it's
a victim of crime
i'm sorry to say this but people are
gonna feel
like more about it if the person is good
looking
well there's the star power
that's what i mean
and it's sad that it happens that way
because
you know if you like if you're ugly and
you get murdered
i feel like people are probably aren't
gonna care as much
is it if you're like a little a little
white girl who's like super cute yeah
and you get murdered then yeah
everybody's gonna like [ __ ] flip the
white girl find the white girl yeah and
it's just like and it's a problem i mean
you know what i mean and i've heard like
a lot of you know people that are
interested crime a lot of people that
investigate this kind of stuff they're
like it's a it's a real big problem
because obviously everybody nobody
deserves to get murdered or kidnapped or
whatever but people are gonna put more
resources even if they don't realize
that they're doing it into
victims that are good looking and the
same thing happens like with criminals i
kind of look at the [ __ ] [ __ ] around
ted bundy or like the [ __ ] or that or
that [ __ ] up in uh
heard that was who was that was her name
carla hamulka and her boyfriend the ken
and barbie killers yeah
um everybody was like all up in that
because like look how good looking they
are looking and they're killing people
and they're killing people yeah killing
good-looking girls that's what they were
doing yeah yeah so
it's it's weird it's like a weird well
it's like sales yeah you know what i
mean it's just like sales and marketing
people have a popular look and [ __ ]
you know what i mean they're they're
going to attract more attention and
they're going oh no not them really
because then then how could a good
looking person get so wrong how could
they be so bad look at that like if
they're ugly then everybody's like oh
well of course
of course it's human nature
humans are evil hairless monkeys that's
what they are
well well no i don't i don't know about
that because like we are aware of it
right i mean a lot of people are aware
it's just instinct
it's human instinct you're like why are
they doing it those are high value
people why are they doing it
because that's called bernardo that's
his name thing yeah i remember her name
but it's not and here's the thing it's
not just
women okay it's also not just white
people
[ __ ] i started [ __ ] working out
and getting bigger no people treat me
differently now better a lot better than
before
and look a real good looking black girl
is going gonna be treated very different
from a [ __ ]
ugly black girl it's gonna be it's gonna
be the same it's the same thing with
white people
an ugly white girl is not gonna be
treated the same as a [ __ ] really
good looking white girl it's just
it's just the way it is
race is only a small part of the factor
it's
how hot you are that's really
what it is
but that's just the way people are
yeah but like i said if you if you're in
law enforcement yeah i do kind of feel
like you have to make a concerted effort
to get over that because obviously well
i think they do yeah well but you have
to be aware of it and like i said i have
read a lot of articles from people in
law enforcement or people that study
that kind of like sociologists and stuff
people that study that it's like look we
really need to get past that bias if
you're in that because you know just
because a little girl is not as cute
right as this little girl it's like that
doesn't mean she deserves less to be
found than this cuter little girl over
here you know because that's [ __ ] up
it's all little girls it's [ __ ] up
you're right you know what i'm saying so
yeah but it is a bias that has to be
overcome they try they do
they do and you know part of another
part of the problem is that there are
just certain [ __ ] areas of the
country that are super high
crime
so many crimes happening in that area
that you just can't keep up with them
all and they try but they just [ __ ]
you know
but luckily those areas are temporary
they come and go quickly because they
kind of depopulate or the [ __ ]
economy changes
you have it where whole cities the whole
wings of cities [ __ ]
collapse and vanish over the decades you
know
bundy data says she looks like patty
hearst oddly she does a bit now that you
mention it i didn't want to do a show
about patty hearst for a long time she's
cuter than petty hers it never wins in
the poll though she cuter one of these
days we'll do a show about petty hers i
always wanted to do a show about petty
hairs i think she's cuter than petty
hers
uh yeah probably yeah probably
yeah so okay so
we're at when when clyde met bonnie so
it's at this house that belonged to
clyde's friend clarence
now at this point clyde was 20 and
bonnie was 19.
now bonnie she had been working as a
waitress but she either quit or got
fired or whatever but she'd been staying
with a friend of hers
um she had a broken arm for some reason
uh and she was staying there like kind
of recovering and she was out of work at
the time
clyde
uh dropped by this house for whatever
reason
he goes into the kitchen and reportedly
bonnie is in there making some hot
chocolate and it was like instant
supposedly like everybody that was there
said it was like instant like love at
first sight yeah you know what i mean
which i don't know but that's what a lot
of people said they said they were just
immediately like smitten with one
another i'm gonna try to pull up a good
photo of [ __ ] clive barrel go ahead
yeah cause he was like a good looking
dude yeah yeah he's good he's he like i
said they were both good-looking people
so i think that really like helped with
their uh
with with their notoriety i guess
because they were both good-looking
so
yeah so
by all accounts they totally like just
fell in love like immediately
and became like inseparable
over the subsequent like few weeks and
months
uh sadly though
this whole like burgeoning romance
got interrupted because clyde
got arrested not too long after they met
and convicted of auto theft
now at this point
uh april 1930 he's 21 years old
he gets sent to
eastham prison farm
for the auto theft
now
not too long after he was incarcerated
there he escaped
he actually escaped using a weapon that
that bonnie had uh smuggled into him
uh unfortunately though or fortunately
depending on which side of the [ __ ]
you're on okay there's clyde barrow yeah
that's him
yeah look at his little jug ears yeah
big old ears
that's okay although they kind of it
works for him they compare him to uh
some modern actor
in this
who could play
him what's that guy's name
do you know uh that's uh
tom holland thomas right yeah if you
look at him side by side in it yeah a
guy who plays spider-man
tom holland
yeah i remember because it's the same
name as the guy that directed fright
night yeah that's how i remember
uh
kazuo a yada i'm sorry if i pronounce
your name wrong they were from
the texas please forget bad english oh
texas that's okay yeah they were both
from texas yeah what country are you
from bro
it looks japanese but i'm not really
like the name looks japanese but i'm not
entirely sure so please forgive me if
i'm wrong of that please forgive me if i
butchered your name i'm terrible with
that kind of [ __ ] but uh yeah they were
both from texas and they're like a very
very poor part of texas west allis um
slums
yeah kazuya
yeah yeah that's what i said okay yeah
that sounds like a japanese i think
japanese yeah yeah
uh so yeah so he goes to the farm he
escapes
but then shortly afterward he is
recaptured
now this is probably
i kind of feel like this is a situation
we talk about this because we've done a
lot of shows about like killer couples
and [ __ ] like that
clyde
i kind of feel like prior to this
he's a minor criminal car theft
minor robberies [ __ ] like that like
nothing violent
but
him getting sent to eastham
prison farm
i kind of feel like this was a formative
thing for him had he not been sent there
had the [ __ ] not happened to him
that happened to him there
i don't know if [ __ ] would have gone
down the same way likewise i'm not sure
had bonnie not met clyde
if she would have become a criminal on
her own i don't think so
i don't think no
no she would have been a waitress clyde
i think just would have been a criminal
but maybe just a petty criminal i don't
think he necessarily would have been a
murderer but you know maybe he just like
stole cars and [ __ ] like that but i
think that his time at this prison farm
and the fact of them meeting i think it
was one of those things
yeah when he met her he was already uh
stealing yeah he had a [ __ ] ton of money
he laid it out on her uh
he laid it out on a uh on the table
at the restaurant where she worked at
and [ __ ] showed he showed her how
much money he had
and she was impressed
yeah he says japan well he's like nippon
but that's chip yeah yeah nepal yeah
i lived in korea for a year
yeah i've always wanted to visit japan
actually expensive it is well and and
plus like the the flight is so long long
and i hate flying yeah so it's kind of
like if i went i'd probably have to like
drug myself the whole entire time so i
could just sleep the whole time because
i'm like i hate being on a plane that
long i didn't even like being on a plane
from here to the uk which is only like
eight or nine hours and i was just kind
of like oh my god like [ __ ] kill me
you hate it i hate it flying over the
[ __ ] atlantic ocean [ __ ] that [ __ ]
but yeah so what were you saying no
you were saying something no okay i was
yeah
anyway i was telling okay i'll tell i'll
tell him that uh i was in um
a place called m jim gak
which is in korea
right in the middle of korea in between
north and south korea on the dmz i was
there for a year had a good time i liked
it there but uh didn't get a chance to
see japan
oh that was close
should have should have gone yeah yeah
maybe it will go one of these days yeah
i mean like i said it's gonna when i win
the lottery
that's sad i want there's a lot of
places i want to go but it's like [ __ ]
man i can't afford it i can't afford to
go to the goth clubs there that's what i
mean i can't i can't even afford to like
drive down the [ __ ] street much less
like
fly around the [ __ ] world so there's
that
so yeah so he goes to the prison farm he
escapes but then he gets
sucked back in
now clyde
very famously called eastham prison farm
that hell hole yeah hell hole yeah um
basically this wasn't like i mean i'm
sure prisons nowadays are no walk in the
park i'm not saying that back in those
days but back in those days they didn't
really have any laws or regulations or
anything like that it's like you could
kind of do i mean the guards would beat
the prisoners murder the prisoners he
would rape the prisoners raped the
prisoners
um they'd put you like in boxes and like
stick you out into the sun they're like
they would do [ __ ] like that yeah now
there was a prison reform that happened
later
matter of fact member of panzram carl
panzram yeah we did a show about it he
was created
in a prison where they went oh yeah no
no actually it was a boy's home
which is a young prisoner for a prison
for young boys yep and
the sexual
molestation and rape cr turned him into
a monster a monster a monster yep and
then he was thrown into prison and his
favorite guard who took care of him
listen to his whole story ended up later
on growing older and becoming powerful
and reforming america's prison system
based on what he'd heard and saw yep in
carl pans around and we did a show we
did a show on carl pan's rhyme uh a
couple years ago yeah so it's in our
archive
a monster
carl panther was a monster well he was a
rapist
that only raped men he would kill a
woman no i didn't worry about when he
raped him in and and make men rape each
other and then even killed him he was
[ __ ] crazy when that was 30s also
what 1930s i believe it was yeah
he did not give a [ __ ] he didn't he was
crazy well the thing about i kind of
feel like
the
concept
of prison
as a place for rehabilitation which it's
still really not but i kind of feel like
maybe
there's more of that than before but
prior to this i mean back in this era
prison was just seen as it was gonna
yeah we're just gonna we just wanna like
break you yeah as a person we don't give
a [ __ ] about like you going back in
society or anything we just want to be
as [ __ ] cruel and horrible to you as
we can yeah nowadays not not realizing
that that's going to make them worse
like those people
might have to be released at some point
university for criminals
yeah make you meaner but uh nowadays
most states
in the united states they've um
california is still one of the roughest
ones because they just can't control
california
the prison population is [ __ ] crazy
but most states
uh at least
they have basic protection for the
prisoners they don't allow prisoners to
murder and rape one another they they
don't allow they punish people in prison
for due for bad behavior
um but in this day
when they're talking about this story
behavior between prisoners was not
regulated
nope no they didn't give a [ __ ] they
didn't give a [ __ ] what prisoners did to
each other so they would rape murder
each other and they'd be like oh well
and then a prison guard would who if he
was
a sadistic homosexual he would jump in
and
rape [ __ ] prison inmates
and no one could say no one said do
about it no one said boo about it nobody
so that profession attracted bad people
yep as as wardens
well carl panzaram and the warden that
one of the prison guards that took care
of panzeram
ended up becoming a an influential
player in the prison system and he and
he changed it and he wrote a book about
it we we talked about him on that show
yeah we did i forgot his name
but he kind of saved america
from itself when it came to the prison
system because it's like you can't do
this you're making monsters it's like i
understand that people don't have a lot
of sympathy for criminals i don't either
like depending on what you did if you
just did like some minor [ __ ] like
stealing a car whatever i don't give a
[ __ ] about that you shouldn't be [ __ ]
raped and
beat up or [ __ ] like nobody deserves
that come on
um you know it's a different thing if
you're talking about like some sadistic
serial killer or some [ __ ] like that but
obviously i mean just for the sake of
society as a whole whether you're
talking about like punishing that one
person i was just from a practical
standpoint
don't put somebody in an environment
where they are treated
as though they are
worse than nothing as though they are
just they can just be like beat and
killed and raped with impunity that's
really not gonna help anything
especially if that person is gonna have
to be released at some point in the
future like if they just did some minor
crime like i said like clyde did like
stealing cars or turkeys or whatever and
then he gets put in this place when he's
like you know 20 21 years old and then
gets like beat up and raped and [ __ ]
like that
yeah um and then he's gonna be released
later on
uh you're releasing a demon
yeah you're making people into monsters
right yeah is what you're doing
kazuo says he's in nihon okay
i don't really know where that is okay
neha i'm not entirely hopefully you can
understand our english if you have any
questions just go ahead and drop it in
the comments i mean because our our
english it's it's
now drunk it's drunk so you better get
your drink it's drunk english
i think i've been doing okay with this
now you're doing great you're doing a
great job i think i've been doing okay
with this wearing though
i haven't i don't know i i i swear a lot
and i can't talk like without talking
about much so i'm sorry if i were good
i haven't really had anybody complain
about that lately so maybe everybody
that complained about it is [ __ ] off
which you know good written it's good
riddance but yeah so i don't really know
like i said back then they just kind of
felt like the whole thing was like oh
well if you do like just a minor crime
we're gonna put you in prison and then
they can just like treat you like the
worst [ __ ] [ __ ] ever and i was like
that's not that's not good for anybody
and like
i don't know it's
to me it doesn't make any sense to me
but okay
so yeah so they treated the prisoners
horribly no matter what they were in
prison for
uh
so in this prison farm and it wasn't
like a prison like a high security
prison i've seen like um
there was a documentary about it where i
was it's obviously not still
you know in service anymore it's but as
far as like when this uh documentary was
made it was a bbc documentary i don't
know what year it came out but they had
the guy like he went to this place and
it's still kind of there but it's like
abandoned obviously so it's all like
[ __ ] up and everything but
it's not like a high security like big
walls with the barbed wire and [ __ ] like
that it was like a farm so it was like a
labor camp essentially it was like a
forced labor camp
now while
clyde was in this
prison farm
um
yeah he was beaten up he was abused and
[ __ ] like that but the big thing was
that he was repeatedly raped
by this other
inmate
now this other inmate was a guy named
big ed
crowder they called him big ed
because he was six feet tall and 200
pounds so he was like much bigger
than clyde um i don't think clyde was
the only inmate the only other inmate
that he raped i think he would just pick
on anybody that was littler than him
which was pretty much everybody and so i
kind of feel like most people thought
that they didn't really have any
recourse
to say anything about it
so
yeah so he raped clyde many many times
uh
until
clyde decided he had had enough of this
[ __ ] and like i said i'm side i'm i'm
team clyde on this one i'm just gonna
say i understood i understand why i did
this and i don't think he should have
gotten trouble at all
he um
lured big ed
into the
the bathrooms
which were all open uh of the prison
farm and he uh basically beat him to
death with a pipe like he crushed his
skull
now
i don't know i'm assuming that he worked
this out prior but he so he crushed the
dude's skull you know after he raped him
repeatedly and like i said i don't think
clyde was the only inmate he raped i
think he was kind of known for doing
because he was bigger than everybody
else big crowder was the name was his
name
so he was a predator sexual predator
yeah so he like did him so clyde said
i'm not having any more of this yeah so
he beat him to death
uh so he had worked it out apparently
with this other inmate who was named
aubry scally
now aubry scally was already serving a
life sentence for highway robbery
and he apparently uh was friends with
clyde and he said i'll take the rap i'm
already in here like they can't do
anything more to me so
so he said that he did it
now interestingly i looked up some
newspaper articles that came out at the
time that ed crowder was killed
and the newspaper reports all said that
he died in a knife fight
and that he had been stabbed 15 times
that's not true though that's not what
happened
what happened was that clyde barrow
beat him to death with a lead pipe
but
the other guy like took the rap for it
so they just like released that as the
story
now all of the [ __ ] that happened at
this prison farm
made clyde so angry as it would like i
said understandably
that he's like look i'm going to
he kind of started conspiring with this
other prisoner who was uh named ralph
fultz who was 19 at the time welcome
back sis
hey what's up she's talking she just
jumped in
i've just gotten here and first thing i
hear is about raped by big ed yeah it
sounds like a bad time yeah we're
already talking about sex it really does
i mean
yeah like i said i don't excuse
this is just like we were talking about
ned kelly and all this other kind of
stuff look and we talked about the
serial killers
the [ __ ] that happened in the past it
doesn't excuse what they did in the
future because a lot of people had
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happen and then in love
and didn't like go on to kill other
people but
i understand it i understand where
you're coming from with that it was
[ __ ] up that shouldn't have happened
to you
you probably should have done the [ __ ]
you did later but
i'm willing to give you a little bit of
a rage within sure so and i get that i
do yeah i get it yeah not everybody
reacts the same way yeah
now
oh well i want to say something uh
what's his name um
what's the japanese name
kazuyu yaida
he he must be in here because i was
talking about out because i was talking
about uh
shimon musashi he must have heard me
talk about musashi maybe yeah i read
musashi
he's a great japanese warrior great
great man great man
wise very wise
good
but yeah so he starts conspiring with
this other inmate ralph fultz who would
later kind of like join his gang off and
on
and he's like look one of these days
we're gonna get out of this prison
we're gonna get a gang together and
we're gonna come back and [ __ ] raid
this place and like kill everybody so a
lot of people think that maybe
clyde barrow's whole thing about we're
just gonna like [ __ ] kill them all
like god sort them out kind of started
from this it was mostly like hatred
against
this particular prison farm like all the
authorities there that had [ __ ] him
over
he got raped he got abused other you
know and other inmates did as well and
he's just like i hate this place more
than any other place on earth and he
just wanted revenge
against this particular place and he did
get it sort of like later on but it was
kind of one of his big motivating things
like throughout his life i feel like so
there was that
so yeah so that was his first murder was
big ed crowder and like i said good
riddance gotta say i mean you know i'm
sure no one's gonna mourn that [ __ ]
guy
now interestingly uh because this is a
prison farm and like i said it was like
all fours it didn't have big walls or
anything like that but it was like
forced labor
uh so you had to like work out in the
fields and clyde didn't really want to
do that
so he decided um
he either did it or he had somebody else
do it um i suspect he probably did it
himself he cut off two of his toes with
an axe yeah yeah in 1932 so he wouldn't
have to do it and also maybe he thought
that he would get out of prison earlier
like if he did that now uh because of
that like i said i think he did it
himself
at least according to
his sister-in-law's account which she
wrote when she was in prison later on
like after the whole [ __ ] happened
um she said that he cut off his toes so
i guess that he did it himself he cut
off his own toes
who needs toes [ __ ] come on he's trying
to work
i'm trying to get out of work
okay he's putting on a sexual
tyrannosaurus yeah become a sexual
tyrannosaurus rex
getting more sexual
why because we were talking about
talking about it's talking about man
rape
talking about everything and we're
talking about prison and cutting off
toes toes with an axe yeah that's pretty
hardcore i mean you really really have
to want to get out of work to like cut
your own toes off with an axe gonna say
it would take me a lot to do something
else and it [ __ ] slipped
and he's like yeah yeah i did that i
don't know
i don't think so i think he did it on
purpose
now like i said some accounts said that
maybe he got somebody else to do it but
i don't know according to his
sister-in-law he did it himself i'm not
worried about it but i'm just saying
yeah you got to really not want to work
time
i kind of respect that
i don't want to work in this prison farm
so much that i'm going to cut my own
[ __ ] toes off all right that's fair
enough yeah well let's go that far kazuo
did you see lone wolf and cub
did you see lone wolf and cub the the
three movie series a c3 or from four
movies it's no it's like 26 movies isn't
it no it's six it's six six movies yeah
i was thinking of dodging i was thinking
she gave me the whole movie series man
with katsushin katsushin's brother in it
man
that's a good one
how to get that [ __ ] show it to you
great movie
glenn little says in kelly's day they
call this high yeah man come on
that means yeah right yeah i know
i know i know yeah i know that much
yeah he's glenn little says american
dude pretending to be japanese
you don't know that i don't know that
but yeah yeah you're just talking about
things my inner stinks tell me that okay
yeah your instincts right
glenn little says in kelly's day they
call that knocking on joe yeah that's
right nick cave wrote a song about it i
love that [ __ ] song actually that's
on his second firstborn is dead
uh one of my favorite nick cave songs
matter of fact
so yeah so he cuts off his own toes
now because of this he actually had a
limp for the rest of his life which
wasn't very long spoiler alert but
what he didn't know was that behind the
scenes his mom
was advocating to like get him out of
this place early like he didn't know
what she was doing i guess so six days
after he cut the toes off
they came in and said okay you're free
like your mom engineered it so he was
like [ __ ] me
like me i'm imagining [ __ ] me i kept my
toes off for no reason and now i have to
limp the rest of my life but you know
what i mean
so he got paroled
in february of 1932.
now
obviously because of the [ __ ] that had
happened in him
like happened in there like a lot of his
family and friends and stuff like that
said you know he was like pretty cool
when he went in that place when he came
out he was a completely different person
yeah
his sister said
something awful sure must have happened
to him in prison because he wasn't the
same person when he got out
and one of the most famous quotes about
this was uh from a friend of his uh his
friend
uh another inmate ralph said
that he watched clyde change from a
school boy to a rattlesnake yeah like
right before his eyes which like i said
understandable
so that [ __ ] might have fueled his whole
entire crime spree because he was
[ __ ] mad
he was [ __ ] mad yeah
like i said prison is university for
criminals
yeah that's what it is i don't really
it's training
yeah because all they do is hang out
with other criminals yeah and fight each
other and fight each other and get
treated shittily and like yeah and learn
why would that make you want to do the
fitness why would that make you want to
be any better like when you get out yeah
i kind of feel like i don't know i kind
of feel like if you're going to have
prison because i you know you do need
prison because some people really need
to be away from the population for a
while
because of what the [ __ ] they did
but
i kind of feel like one if you didn't do
anything super violent
don't put them in with other violent
criminals that's dumb and it's like also
you have to
if somebody's just going in for a short
stint
please keep in mind that this person has
to go back into the community at some
point so let's try to mitigate let's try
to like make this whole transition
easier don't make them like a worse
criminal than they were than they went
in when they went in
you know what i mean it just seems like
common sense
but
i don't know why they put like hardened
criminals in the same place alongside
people that just had like [ __ ] like
drug conviction convictions and [ __ ]
like that
you know what i mean yeah i don't know
it just seems like two completely
different things
and like i said keep in mind that some
people have to be released back out in
the community you don't want to like
make somebody
even worse
than when they went in there which seems
to be the case in this situation
okay so the guy we got in the comments
from japan kazuya is a famous
bartender famous japanese bartender
they're trolling us good there is a
famous brother yeah yeah yeah he's
trolling
so what's in a dirty girl scout
i don't know
i'm not asking you i'm asking the famous
right yeah he's a famous japanese
famous japanese just google this [ __ ]
he's a famous japanese [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's a famous japanese bartender same
photo and everything
that's funny so so yeah so after clyde
got out of uh eastham
he started doing a lot of robberies
mostly minor [ __ ] gas stations grocery
stores little storage like [ __ ] like
that
um
his favorite weapon as i'm sure tom will
be very happy to point out yeah the
m1918 browning automatic rifle or bar
yeah
that was like his gun of choice just
like just like the ford v8 like which
had new come out was his carb choice
yeah but it wasn't the bar that you know
you know i mean it was his was his was
customized he had a shortened stock
shortened barrel by a few inches and
then he put a reinstall the flash
suppressor on the end of the remember
crux i think he still had the flash
suppressor so he had a shorter version
of it he was trying to take the bar and
turn it into what we call an assault
rifle
he even um
took two magazines
and connected them together to try to
make a 30 round or a 40 round magazine
but he had that
and he had he had that done by some good
gunsmiths
that he had access to driving through
who knew who he was
you're like yeah i'll make you some cool
guns
and um
no he liked that one and it
at that particular time in history that
was a pretty decent choice some people
would say well why don't you go for the
uh
thompson submachine gun
a submachine gun fires pistol caliber
ammunition it just doesn't have the
penetration especially back in those
days
in those days car bodies were a lot
heavier
and the uh
some the thompson submachine gun fired
45 acp which was not good for armor
penetration really
good directly on flesh but behind steel
nine millimeter was a lot better
and thompson wasn't available in nine
millimeter
it was limited to it it was available in
38 super but
those were harder to find and the
ammunition wasn't quite as common
so he
went with 30 odd six which is a second
large-sized rifle caliber
take care of the problem
chew a car right up the ammunition was
heavier
couldn't carry as many magazines it was
only a 20 round magazine for it but
in that era you would outgun anybody if
you had a short barreled bar
he had the butt stock cut down but
there's a buffer inside of bar buttstock
a metal buffer
tubes in it
but they had it kind of strategically
cut down where you could kind of sling
it he could sling this thing
underneath this coat and go up into a
bank or a store and pull it out
it was still probably kind of like the
size of a
16 inch m16a2 or usually
16-inch ar-15 just like that you know
about that big
heavy though
but
for the 1930s he was running with
state-of-the-art equipment
state-of-the-art customized equipment
and i saw a lot of different pistols
through the photographs that they used
mostly things like 1911's
good
murder hornet says if i got my booty
hook i'd be a rattlesnake too yeah i'm
sure most people would
uh camp guy says lots of killers were
abused in juvenile jails when they were
kids that's true almond fish
comes to mind as one that was horribly
abused yeah you can't treat people like
that particularly as children like
during like formative years up until
like the teenage years you can't treat
people like that and expect them to come
out okay
yeah you just can't
um
some of them some of them will but and
like i said i'm not excusing like serial
killers because a lot of them were
abused as children but
that's just what just treat everybody
nice jesus christ you don't like it
especially like kids and teenagers for
christ's sake and you would think in
that era a lot of straight guys got
raped in those kind of prisons they
probably and they uh took it okay you
know shook it off
uh but i think cause barrow was bisexual
he took more offense i think
it meant more
be like kind of like raping a woman they
get pissed more pissed over it
[ __ ] um but panzram grew up in that
environment he was just a sex demon
you know the ultimate [ __ ]
leather daddy of death
he hated men
but he was attracted to him weird weird
had no interest in women
well that might have uh been part of his
problem too because i kind of feel like
maybe it wasn't as acceptable like you
couldn't really like maybe because i
kind of feel like there was a lot of
like
particularly before
you know being gay was acceptable
um
if you felt that way you felt like there
was something wrong with you so there
was like a lot of self-hatred going on
yeah which might have in a certain type
of personality might have manifested in
a particularly murderous kind of yeah
because if you ask me i think panzram
was gay too but he hated that but he
hated that right yeah and he had been
yeah so he's gonna rape everybody else
if it's a power thing like this was done
to me and you made me feel like a victim
and made it like right if you could rape
a straight guy and then he turns into a
sex monster because of rape
then there would be a [ __ ] ton of them
because there was probably a [ __ ] ton of
straight guys that got raped
but they didn't they don't end up doing
that
well it has to be as i said it's always
like nature and nurture yeah you know
yeah it's only probably
going to be a small percentage of people
that are going to like lash out
in the way that like a serial killer
would or like a particularly like you
know egregious criminal would
but
i'm just saying you don't you never know
who's gonna act out like that later so
just like don't do that to anybody in
panzram's case though because he had no
interest in women and had no female
victims
he was gay
he was gay and he was a rapist and a
saddest and a murderer
so i always kind of wonder one of the
fascinating things to me about like
serial killers are you know people that
end up doing [ __ ] like this is kind of
like
had they been born in a different era
yeah would they have turned out okay
like maybe not okay but would they have
not been a serial killer maybe yeah
probably not yeah i think it's right
place right time wrong person in the
wrong place at the wrong time yeah
because i kind of feel like it's not
just the person it's not just yes
there's some people that are genetically
predisposed to be that particular way
but i think there has to be like a
confluence of
factors and a lot of those are like
societal like would either like just in
their family like their immediate family
or in society at large
so
you know i kind of feel like had some
people been born in a different era
then you know like you know we talked
about this when we talked about jeffrey
dahmer for example it's like had jeffrey
dahmer been born into a different family
or been born later
um do i think he would have been a
serial killer maybe not
maybe not um
you know i don't know
you know we can't run that experience
experiment obviously but
so i don't know it's just kind of
interesting it's always kind of like
it has to be that person at that time
in that societal
you know kind of framework
that shit's gonna turn out that way
had it been a different time and place
maybe not it might not have worked out
like that
so
yeah so after he gets out of prison
clyde
in 1932
him and his friend ralph who had been an
inmate and also got out they started
doing all these robberies as i mentioned
mostly like just little [ __ ] gas
stations uh store stuff like that their
whole goal during this time period was
like we're gonna rob all these places
and we're gonna get enough money so we
can buy some guns and we're gonna go
back to easton prison farm and we're
gonna [ __ ] it up we're gonna like let
all the prisoners out we're gonna like
kill the guards we're gonna do that so
they want to do like a raid so that's
kind of like what their initial goal was
now while they were doing because bonnie
was helping them at the time too like on
these robberies so april 19th of that
year which is 1932
um ralph and bonnie actually got they
were trying to like uh
they were trying to rob a hardware store
in kaufman
and they were gonna like steal some guns
and they both got arrested but clyde
didn't
now bonnie uh
got released after a couple months uh
she didn't you know she didn't get
indicted
now ralph got tried and convicted and
served some time
and after that like just drifted away
from the gang and like never rejoined
now while bonnie was in prison like for
the few months she was in for this
particular job
she kind of like you know wrote a bunch
of poems and stuff like that like you
can look up like a lot of her poems are
like kind of famous
and she got out and then clyde was
waiting there for her so you know they
kind of hooked back up a couple weeks
after she got out
now there was another
uh robbery in hillsborough this was
april 30th 1932.
now
this particular robbery according to
most reports that i saw
the owner of the store who was a guy
named jn uh bucher buker i guess
he got shot and killed
now
even though
uh
the victim's wife identified clyde from
police photographs
as one of the people that had shot her
husband
most reports say that clyde was still in
the car
that it was the other
people that were in the so they don't
really know if clyde like actually shot
the dude they think he was just like the
getaway driver
but he still got blamed because he was
kind of the one that was
more well-known i guess but like the
other two people like uh you know they
they were probably the ones that did it
so not too long after that like a couple
months later
clyde and a couple other dudes
are
in this place in oklahoma like drinking
and then there's a sheriff named sheriff
maxwell and a deputy deputy moore
and the two cops
come up to them like in the parking lot
because i guess like they recognized
them because of this whole like guy that
they had shot back in april
um
and i guess clyde and the gang were not
having it and so they started shooting
so basically um
more got uh
killed
and maxwell was
wounded
so
this was actually the first cop that he
had killed
now
there was another incident in october of
that year where there was supposedly
this robbery in sherman texas
although i think that maybe that was
other people i think that just got like
attributed to them later on now here's
this other dude named wd jones he was
like a teenager
now he had known clyde's family since
they were all kids
and he ended up joining the gang when he
was 16 years old uh uh christmas 1932.
and the three of them
ended up leaving dallas
uh
and the next day which was christmas day
of 1932
jones and clyde
ended up murdering another dude who
wasn't a cop
it was a guy named doyle johnson
now he they were stealing his car
and they killed him in
uh
you know in the course of stealing's car
in temple texas
later on clyde killed a guy named taran
like a guy named malcolm davis who was
tarrant county deputy
that was january 1933
and then that was when he bonnie and uh
w d jones they had kind of gone into a
like a police trap which had not been
set for them but was separate
oh and it was gonna
going to happen
good time it's okay i knew this is going
to happen
damn throw hurting yeah
when i get a cold
and then it goes away yeah
a lot of times like it'll just like my
throat will tickle okay like for a
couple weeks afterward and it'll be like
so i'll try if i try to talk for a long
time like i'll have like a coughing [ __ ]
so i was hoping i wouldn't do it on the
show but you know sorry it'll be all
right
yeah probably now it's time for a super
chat people go ahead
[Laughter]
for jenny's medical yeah for jenny's
medical [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uncle here
but yeah so there have been a police
trap set for
some other random criminal
and apparently
clyde and bonnie and wd like wandered
into it
without knowing so they kind of like had
to shoot their way out
so they ended up shooting another cop
so 1933
in march of 1933
clyde's older brother
buck who had been in prison for some
other [ __ ] because like i said they had
done some [ __ ] earlier on
but he got out
now he had a wife named blanche
and him and blanche like moved in with
bonnie and clyde and wd jones they were
kind of like in this sort of hideout
in joplin missouri this house
now
apparently i don't know i i think that
maybe buck and blanche at first were
kind of like telling clyde hey maybe you
should turn yourself in
but
i don't know i don't know if that's true
or not
the thing about it though was this house
which was their hideout they weren't
really like seeming to
make much of an effort to like
keep on the dl you know what i'm saying
they were kind of like
they would like do these big card games
they would like
they were really loud
they would like fire guns
accidentally or on purpose like into the
street they would do [ __ ] like that um
blanche said in her diaries which they
found later on because like a friend of
hers had them said they bought a case of
beer a day
and the guys would like come and go at
all hours
like i said they would shoot the guns in
the apartment while they were cleaning
whoops it went off it was [ __ ] like that
yeah now the neighbors because they had
neighbors uh they were kind of too
scared to go over there but one of them
or one or more of them like called the
cops i was like what the [ __ ] is going
on over there like they're just making
shooting guns in the apartment shooting
guns in the apartment it's like we think
maybe there's like some nefarious [ __ ]
going on i used to do it but we'll talk
about later
this guy know what you're doing you
gotta make a good [ __ ] bat you gotta
make it with a bullet stop yeah
okay yeah
no big calibers little calibers i mean
come on now don't shoot your beer are
inside there no no
he says it was accidental
while he was cleaning it
he's lying he was probably drunk yeah
he's like
oh
well oh damn we have neighbors yeah it's
just i forgot yeah yeah so they call the
cops now the cops
didn't know and like i said they weren't
like bonnie and clyde at this point they
like they were kind of known but they
weren't like famous yeah so the cops at
this point they didn't know that it was
them like it was the barrow gang they
thought
it was bootleggers which like i said
this was during like prohibition still
yeah so if you were drinking
you'd be in trouble like we would be in
trouble like right now is what i'm
saying
if somebody knew we were drinking in
here like back at this time yeah
so the cops get together this uh it's
like five guys in two cars and they kind
of like drive to this house because they
think oh [ __ ] there's like bootleggers
we're gonna like bust them
now the cops get there
and clyde
and his brother
uh buck and wd jones just started
shooting
because you know cops they're coming to
get us like i said clyde said it i'm not
being taken alive yeah uh so they just
started shooting
so they actually ended up killing uh
detective harry l mcginnis
outright
fatally wounding another constable jw
harryman
bonnie also opened fire with a bar as
the others ran away
uh and then like one of the other cops
like kind of duck behind a tree like to
keep from getting shot
uh so basically like he kind of got like
some wood splitters into his face i
think that's the i think that's the one
where bonnie actually made one of her
best shots in that one
um you don't you didn't collect the
actual
details about where they were what the
ranges were in that one did you
no okay all right just see because uh
the source that i remember reading i
think it was something where they were
getting ready to be apprehended and they
shot their way out of it from an
apartment
and it sounds like that same
situation there
and that shot that they talk about she
that she took
was
on the on the move
from the hip
at a mo she was moving that's what i
mean by on the move
and she was shooting at a running cop
who was shooting at her at the same time
and i think it was like
i think it was 75 yards
it might have been because i think she
was running toward the car because they
were trying to like get the [ __ ] out of
there and he might have been like
running like to duck behind the tree
behind a tree or something taking cover
and it was like i think it was close to
set
75 yards if i remember it's either 50 or
75 yards when the heat of combat that's
far
okay
it's not far
when you actually look
on paper of what the maximum effective
range of these other firearms is but
none of that [ __ ] on paper that you hear
in gun tube on [ __ ] youtube none of
that [ __ ] actually means a [ __ ]
doesn't mean anything
in real life in real life it's a it's a
it's a [ __ ] contact sport like
football and it's
and
the the time scale you're talking about
is seconds
so there's no time to think no time to
act no time to aim everything is
instinctive shooting
and
uh if it's the same shooting i remember
they shot their way out of there and
[ __ ] and and [ __ ] bonnie had a
[ __ ] great instinctive
shot on that [ __ ] uh detective and
killed him crumpled his ass up
well she didn't kill that one he ducked
behind a tree duck pine tree okay
okay then there's then then i'm it's
it's the wrong incident then
in one incident she she crumpled a
[ __ ] guy up and i think it was at 75
yards while she was running and he was
running thank you stardoll and she did
it from the hip
while on the move
so much
she didn't she didn't kill the one she
shot at she hit the tree that he was
hiding behind okay because he ducked by
and it's not it's not the guy that got
killed was either clyde or buck okay so
it's not the same engagement actually
they killed two guys they killed two
cops like brothers did right i i saw the
play-by-play of every [ __ ] thing that
they did and some of the feats that
happened in combat some of their combat
feats off the cuff just instant shooting
and uh they were good they were real
good you wouldn't want to go up against
them
you know but you're forced to you know
just just just that's the nature of law
enforcement you know you got to take
them out
and that was why frank hamer did what he
did later on but go ahead
so yeah so they're all running like
trying to get back in the car yeah
bonnie gets in the car
they had to run
they had to drive down the street and
pick up blanche who was buck's wife
because she had a little dog named
snowball that had run away like during
all the fighting and was like running
down the street so she was chasing the
dog she's like i have to get snowball
back which like i said i feel that i
feel that you gotta go get your pet
although i don't think that she found
him i think he just ran away was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm not
about firefighters i'm not about
firefighting and i'm just gonna go find
another family yeah it's like less
stressful like go go snowball yeah but
yeah so but she was chased so they had
to like pick her up like on the way
now
the officers that survived
said that they had fired
14 rounds
during this firefight uh one actually
hit wd jones the teenager in the side
one hit clyde but actually ended up
hitting one of his the buttons on his
coat and like bounced off
one just kind of grazed buck who was uh
clyde's older brother and then
ricocheted off after ricocheting off the
wall okay now i'm gonna say something
about this
okay well we're in the bathroom around
hitting your button bouncing off i'm
gonna call direct [ __ ] on that
they probably thought that happened but
that couldn't have happened
the agents would have been doing they
would have been carrying something like
45 acp
38 super
38 special
those were the main ones 38 super
actually that was the new one that came
out so that was that would have been
[ __ ] that would have been a top dog
caliber
or 32 acp
okay
which would have been the weakest
a lot of dudes carried 32.
32 acp was the 9 millimeter parabellum
of its era that was kind of like the
super gun caliber
but 32 is weak
this is to the gun guys
even 32 acp
would penetrate something like a metal
button it would go right through it
so that that's got to be an error there
um
the weakest caliber they had would not
have been deflected
by a button on somebody's jacket it must
have been a bullet fragment
it's got to be
a bullet fragment is as the [ __ ]
round comes in it hits something it
[ __ ] splatters it shatters you know
it splatters maybe it's [ __ ]
38 special and it doesn't have a jacket
on the bullet and the [ __ ] lead comes
and hits the [ __ ]
splat it splatters it fragments and the
[ __ ] lead comes and hits his [ __ ]
button and he goes oh man my button
absorbed around but no i i know better i
understand ballistics too much and know
what they do even the weakest thing they
had
would not have been stopped by
somebody's button not a direct hit it
had to have been a [ __ ]
a ricochet
or a
lead splatter off a 38 special it had to
been good
so okay so i kind of feel like this
particular shootout
was the thing that sort of made them
like nationwide news
not just because they'd killed a couple
cops but
because
they were forced to flee from their
apartment obviously
um they left all their ship behind one
of the things they left behind was their
camera
and this camera had a whole bunch of
rolls of undeveloped film in it and the
cops developed all the film
and from this from these rolls of film
came the infamous photographs straw dog
sent us ten dollars thank you very much
yeah i know i got that a long time ago
okay i got that a long time ago thank
you very much jimmy's on top of it yeah
you just well that's what happens when
you don't listen like what i say
but yeah so i kind of feel like
i don't know like i said i i think they
still would have been famous but the
fact that they found these photographs
and had them developed and then like the
media got hold of them and published
them it kind of made them like a
nationwide sensation particularly that
one
uh that very famous iconic photo of
bonnie
like kind of with her leg cocked up on
the car with the cigar and the gun and
everything like that so everybody was
just kind of like enraptured by like
this whole situation
so yeah
front page news
now over the next a little while like
the next three months or so the gang
starts kind of going
from texas they're going like all
through the like the middle part of the
united states like wait they went as far
north as minnesota they're just like all
over the place
now they tried to rob a bank in indiana
and then they robbed another bank in
minnesota
at this particular one they kidnapped a
couple people no this was later this was
in louisiana they kidnapped a couple
people when they were stealing someone's
car
and so basically
they did kidnap some people like cops or
people that they were trying to steal
their car or whatever now sometimes they
would take the people with them for a
while like as you mentioned and then
they usually wouldn't kill them they
would usually like release them
like several states away from home and
but they would give them some money and
be like hey
have a good time like if like get back
to where you [ __ ] came from well
pretty much releasing them several
states away meant that you slowed down
response time that's right yeah true
they knew what they were doing because
like i said
back in the old days everything could
just like go to like a [ __ ] yeah you
could go to like another [ __ ] state
and it was like the [ __ ] never even
happened yeah it was like totally it was
like going to a different country or
like a different planet
another planet yeah
no so i will say even though they did
let people live they were kind of famous
at this time
but
i mean if you were a cop and you tried
to like [ __ ] arrest them they were
just gonna shoot you and like not
[ __ ] think about it
so a lot of them did
even though there was kind of like i
kind of feel like there was a lot of
public sympathy toward them at least at
first
but as time went on and sort of like
news filtered out about like the murders
that they committed because it wasn't
just cops that they killed they killed
like
regular ass people whose cars they were
trying to steal too yeah if you resisted
they killed you yeah or like you know if
they were just like robbing a store they
when you [ __ ] with them they would
kill you yeah so i think that kind of
like tipped like public sympathy away
from right right i mean i feel like
there was romantic they were kind of
romanticized yeah
they were romanticized but in their
defense
everything that i [ __ ] heard or
remembered
if you resisted they killed you if you
scared them they were killed they killed
you
if you surrendered they let you live
all right then they'd sometimes abduct
you and then let you go after that
so they tried to avoid it they were
criminals they were they were kind of
not saying they were good people if
that's where you want to put it you know
but um
no if you if any kind of resistance any
kind of [ __ ] um
threatening move while they were robbing
you they shot you
and you died yeah they absolutely had no
yeah
they didn't really happen yeah they made
it clear doing that they made it clear
if you lifted a finger against them they
kill you
which that was
that was the philosophy you surrender
immediately
surrender you'll be rewarded
resist you're killed
yeah that's there were no great pretty
much yeah there was no gray area yeah
that seemed like pretty much what they
uh lived by right
so uh after the photos came out and they
pretty much became known nationwide like
what their faces looked like um and one
of the photos actually a couple of the
photos showed like the license plate on
the car and [ __ ] like that so now they
were famous all over the country
which
uh made [ __ ] a lot harder for them
because
you know
they're trying to live on the run and
everything like that right now you know
the celebrities trying to eat at
restaurants and trying to stay at hotels
and [ __ ] like that but now a lot of
people recognize them so it's obviously
making [ __ ] a lot harder
so according to uh blanche
who was uh you know
clydeberry's sister-in-law
who was with them
uh she was like during this time it's
like we were just in the car for hours
and hours and hours i mean they were
just literally living on the road
and after they got famous they couldn't
really stop at hotels as often because
they were recognized so it's like they
would have to like take baths in streams
and it's like they'd have to do [ __ ]
like that or like cook over they'd have
to like camp out in the woods and crap
like that and they said we were in the
car together for like hours and hours
and hours at a time and so like
everybody was getting like really cranky
like having to deal with one another so
there was that so like it wasn't
glamorous at all like everybody's just
in the car sniping at one another they
were all stinky they couldn't stop
anywhere because they'd be recognized
and so they started like fighting that
was all kind of [ __ ] like that
so um i think like a couple of them you
like even like took off at some points
you're like look i can't deal with this
anymore so there was that kind of [ __ ]
too
now what ended up happening somebody
talking uh somebody mentioned earlier
like that um
that bonnie had had like a an injury to
her leg this is where this happened
this is june 10th yeah it wasn't
somebody said that it was a some kind of
a [ __ ] congenital defect i don't
think it was a good condition no no no
no no
no yeah and this is where it happened it
happened while they were on the run this
was in 1932 i think uh june 10th
now they're driving
clyde was driving
and there was a bridge under
construction
clyde didn't see the sign
and he flipped the car into a ravine
now they don't know like
some accounts say the car caught fire
uh some accounts say that the car's
battery like the acid came out of the
car's battery like into the floorboards
or whatever
whatever happened
um bonnie's leg
was [ __ ] up third degree burns to her
right leg pretty much from her hip to
her ankle
um
so severe that the muscles contracted
and caused the leg to like kind of like
drop like that uh w d jones who was with
them at the time was a teenager said
this is a quote she'd been burned so bad
none of us thought she was going to live
the hide on her right leg was gone from
her hip down to her ankle i could see
the bone in places damn
i realized it was that bad so yeah it
was [ __ ] up now some people might say
well how the hell do you wreck a car in
the okay those old cars that they drove
they weren't very fast but they were
heavy
they were heavy when in comparison to
the amount of power you had
and no hydraulic brakes they were
mechanical brakes
it took a long time to slow one down the
steering was [ __ ]
and in those and another thing is this
no paved roads we were talking about
dirt roads
so once you got that thing up moving 35
40 miles an hour
hard to keep it under control and if you
try to stop it especially during the
turn now you can roll it easily
those things are [ __ ] handled for
they handled for [ __ ]
were
they
not modern cars
glorified
buggy
a glorified horse buggy
with a bunch of weight on it
so yeah easy easy to [ __ ] up
easy to wreck yeah and and it did wreck
and she yeah she got super [ __ ] up
narrow tires on them
mechanical steering they're rough
so after this she basically just had to
hop around on one leg or clyde had to
carry her which is not super convenient
when you're like on the run from the law
like 24 7.
now
they did have
kind of a local family
uh on a farm that sort of helped them
like you know for a short time
then they ended up kidnapping uh two
other cops which was uh county sheriff
george corey and city marshal paul hardy
uh they didn't kill them they left them
actually like handcuffed to a tree uh
that was in oklahoma
and then they met back up with buck and
blanche
and then they hid in this place which
was like a tourist camp type place
uh and they were kind of like trying to
fix i mean because obviously they
couldn't take bonnie to a hospital
because everybody knew who they were
uh at this point buck and wd jones went
to do another robbery and ended up
murdering another cop a town marshal
named henry de humphrey humphrey that
was in arkansas
and so they had to go on the run again
even though bonnie could barely walk
so july of 1933
they end up checking into
this kind of like tourist
court like or i guess it was kind of
like a resort camp or something like
that in missouri
so these are like two
kind of cabins so i don't know if they
were like cabin cabins they were like
brick
and then they were like there were like
garages in the middle
so they rented both of the
cabins
now next to this was like a tavern
or a restaurant
and this restaurant
was kind of a hangout for a lot of like
missouri cops or like the highway patrol
guys
and
i will say that at this point it really
doesn't seem like even though you would
think that they'd be like oh [ __ ]
there's like cops right there they
didn't really seem to be like
all that worried about
they're being like cops right there
because basically blanche went in
to
kind of like you know secure the the
cabins
and she says
okay there's three people
but then like the guy that owns the
place is like well obviously like five
people just got out of the car so that's
like super sketch
also he noticed that like they backed
the car into the garage
like
they backed it in there they're like and
he even called it gangster style like oh
in case we need to like get out of you
know i guess he'd seen a lot of [ __ ]
um but yeah so it's like just
like they needed to get away real quick
um another thing that he thought was
weird was that blanche who was the only
one that came in she paid for the rooms
in coins
which
was weird even for back then
and when they went to the restaurant
later and the bar like they ordered like
food and drinks and stuff like that they
also paid for that with coins which
stuck out
so
they weren't really trying to like
keep it on the down low i mean they were
doing like suspicio suspicious [ __ ] i
don't know if they realized it was
suspicious
but everybody knew it was suspicious
uh also another thing that they did that
was super suspicious
that the owner of the place noticed was
that they had like taped newspaper over
the windows of the cabin so again that
seems a little sketchy
um so yeah
and the way that blanche and that
blanche looked in particular because
like i said this was 1930s
not super super common for women to be
wearing pants
and not super common for women to be
wearing like riding breeches just in a
regular context so the fact that blanche
was going around wearing riding breeches
was also like very suspicious
um so a lot of people like remembered
them like when they saw them like
walking around
so because of that like the owner kind
of goes into the restaurant next door
and it's like hey there's a lot of
weirdos like staying over there maybe
you want to like check that out
another thing that didn't help was that
clyde and wd jones
they go into town
to get like some food
and they also got like some bandages and
some stuff to put on bonnie's leg which
is all [ __ ] up
now because the cops had been thinking
ahead they said okay well obviously they
knew that bonnie's leg had been [ __ ]
up so they said and that she couldn't go
to the hospital so they're like okay
well
they told like pharmacists and stuff
like that in the area hey like why don't
you look out for somebody that's like
that's looking for these particular
things because it'd be suspicious so the
pharmacist in this particular town was
like hey there's like all these people
and these guys just came in and bought
this stuff that you said about so
uh so the upshot of that was that the
cabins were put under surveillance by
the local police
so they ended up getting like a bunch of
uh reinforcements from kansas city they
got an armored car they got like all
kind of stuff
so they said we're gonna like [ __ ]
close in on them because we know that
it's probably them and so they got all
this backup what happened oh i thought
you like
i heard something like you tripped or
some [ __ ] like that
so they said okay well we're gonna get
all this back up we're gonna do this
[ __ ] we're gonna like ambush them
so they kind of get all these cops and
they're gonna go it's like 11 o'clock at
night and they're gonna go
and they're gonna like [ __ ] stalk the
cabins they got thompson submachine guns
they're [ __ ] ready
so they go in there and there's a big
[ __ ] gun fight
now it turned out
that the cops again
outgunned
uh
clyde again had stolen uh
another
uh bar
from the national guard armory in
oklahoma he's just stolen it july 7th
and so
uh so he pretty much like i said like
outgunned the cops out got the cops
now what ended up happening this is like
kind of like a [ __ ] farce right here
a bullet i don't know whose bullet it
was
but some bullet during the gunfight
ended up short-circuiting the horn
on the armored car
and the cops heard that
and thought that it was a signal for
them to cease fire so they did
uh so the gang were like okay lucky us
and they all piled in the vehicle and
got the [ __ ] out of there and for
whatever reason the cops didn't follow
them
so
you know so there was
that now
during the gunfight though
buck clyde's older brother
had got a
a pretty bad gunshot wound
the gun had essentially like blown off
part of his
skull but like in his forehead
and his brain was exposed hold on but
the [ __ ] was still alive and like
talking and acting relatively normal
somebody shot him and did that yeah okay
yeah well during a fight yeah okay
uh so yeah so his head was kind of blown
off but he was still like walking around
blanche uh she'd actually like the gun
the gunfire had like broken a bunch of
glass and it had gone like in a bunch of
her in her eyes so she was kind of like
uh blinded or mostly blinded
so yeah so she was [ __ ] up too
so there was that that was 45 that did
that
45 acp was known for that kind of [ __ ]
with head shots kind of more like a
smashing
it's a little can you imagine being like
walking around with your just [ __ ]
brain like pulsing out like that like
i'm just like like can you put like a
[ __ ] price over that or something
came in on an angle and knocked a big
[ __ ] uh hunk of the bomb i kind of
that's kind of what
i was picking it's probably what
happened it's it's heavy and it's slow
it did like blow a
portion of his skull out of his yeah it
didn't go through and it just it didn't
go through it clipped him it glanced off
but it i mean glanced
enough to like knock part of his skull
knocked part of the face and had his
little brain sticking out yeah but he
could still like walk around and talk
and [ __ ] yeah well she you don't need
that
just put some duct tape over that it'll
be fine to patch it up they didn't have
duct tape back then i don't know well as
long as there's like a [ __ ] there's
like a plastic wrap over the [ __ ] top
of it holding the fluid in
if that shit's intact you can be okay
you just gotta worry about infection
yeah you can't have your brain like just
open to the [ __ ] air jesus christ
who knows what a like [ __ ] crawling
right here yeah christ if you have
antibiotics you patch it up [ __ ] put
a plate in there [ __ ] you know you
fix it up well yeah they can fix it
nowadays but like i said if you're in a
criminal gang who the cops are after
and you can't go to the hospital yeah
because you'll get caught right then
yeah yeah
did they have antibiotics and they had
them in the 30s i think didn't they
anybody came from the 20s didn't it
yeah when was like when was uh like
louis pasteur and all that kind of stuff
yeah i kind of feel like that was me i
don't know how like widely disseminated
they were though at this time period
when you have a student i mean they had
him in world war ii obviously but right
i kind of feel like prior to that it was
kind of like hit or miss yeah you know
what i mean get a situation like that
you got to patch that dead child and
[ __ ] start giving a whole bunch of
antibiotics i mean if that happened to
me i would like immediately slap duct
tape over there yeah well if you have
[ __ ] piece of sheet metal you can
[ __ ] sterilize that and [ __ ] rivet
it or screw it
what the [ __ ] are you doing into the
head
and try to pull some skin over it
oh what did you do i'm looking at pookie
she's [ __ ] pookie you're freaking me
out what is she doing she's acting like
she's getting ready to jump on something
what happened pokey what is it
is it a bug
no
is she pretending she's pretending i
think she's pretending
well she's acting like there's something
like that oh she's no oh okay
she's fighting the [ __ ] stuffed mouse
i couldn't see what it was she was doing
and she was like they're like holy [ __ ]
there's a thing yeah she's [ __ ]
serious about it and then she went up
like that it's a mouse it's like her
it's a little stuffed mouse it's got
it's a white mouse with black stripes on
it like a zebra
and then she's like thrown around like
acting like it's some bigfoot yeah she's
got a bunch of them but she likes that
white one with the black stripes on it
it gets this visual somebody needs to
get rid of this uh naked hd fun webcam
yada yada
who can't who doesn't know how to spell
gay who what you talk about right here
this oh you see that what you doing it's
like yeah yeah oh yeah it's a sex spot
go ahead and get the sex spot out people
i can't do i'll like i don't know why i
can't do it i have the three dots but
obs doesn't let me like uh get it but we
have i mean murder hornets here
tammy's here you guys are mods yeah so
you can get rid of the peeps
all right so after this happens with
[ __ ] buck having ha have his [ __ ]
front of his head blown off so they go
to this like abandoned amusement park in
iowa
this is july 24th
now buck not surprisingly uh kind of in
and out of consciousness because you
know a big portion of his skull is gone
and his brain is sticking out
um
like he could still talk and he still
ate and stuff but
he had lost a lot of blood
and he was
like i said kind of like falling asleep
every now and then
and clyde and wd were like yeah he's
gonna die so they dug him a grave which
that had to that's the spirit
was he still he was still awake he was
still awake awake walking around you're
gonna die there's like hey we're just
gonna just yeah
just in case
i mean you know yeah recover but just in
case that's what's gonna happen nobody
wants his xbod
get the sex box out of here sex sex box
cookie what are you doing
she's being crazy and she's looking
she's looking all sheepish are i'm not
doing anything i'm not doing anything
don't yell at her if she's not doing
anything come here come here come on
don't yell at her she's doing come here
man come here come over the show she's
probably like why are you don't [ __ ]
with me
okay
okay yeah so because they're all walking
around all [ __ ] up with like bloody
bandages and whatnot obviously the local
residents are like what the [ __ ] is
going on there like everybody's walking
around with like [ __ ] bloody heads
and whatnot
so uh
they figured out pretty quickly who they
were so they called the cops
so at this point again a bunch of cops
turn up and a bunch of like random ass
citizens turn up
and
there was again another like [ __ ]
gunfight yeah because everyone's
shooting at them
uh clyde and bonnie and wd jones ran
away so they got away
buck though got shot in the back
and you know he was the one whose uh his
brain was yeah whose brain was sticking
out
uh him and blanche his wife uh got
captured by the cops now buck did
actually end up dying uh later on like
they gave him surgery but you know he
went into surgery but he had a head
wound he had been shot in the back and
he got pneumonia yeah um so five days
after that again so he actually no
antibiotics
yeah i kind of feel like maybe
i don't know if that probably would have
saved him but yeah well pneumonia yeah
antibiotics will fix that
yeah
it's just it's amazing how
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] that people don't
even think about nowadays like you're
taking it for granted would have killed
you back then yeah you know what i mean
yeah a lot of [ __ ] would have killed
people about that yeah
though he's gonna die yeah
well i mean they probably had to like
look at the dude it's like well it looks
like he's walking around and stuff but
look at that ooh look at that yeah
it's like that's not good that's not
good yeah i mean you know
uh so so after that
uh you know bonnie and clyde and wd
jones we're walking we're kind of like
you know running around
for the next month and a half
um now they kind of started going like
farther afield i guess they went out as
far as colorado um they went back up to
minnesota for a little while they went
to mississippi
um they were still doing armed robberies
the whole time
because they still needed money and they
still needed guns
they uh got new guns they robbed an
armory in illinois in august
and they got three new bars some
handguns and a big ass
uh cache of ammunition
so you know
now one thing that they did this is like
crazy
they would like
kind of
build their itineraries around visiting
their families because i guess their
families even though i'm imagining their
families probably knew what they were up
to by this point um
i don't know if they were necessarily
like supportive like yay go you but
they didn't turn them in
you know what i'm saying
it was and like i said
the general populist was [ __ ]
populous was kind of turned against
the institutions of the of the country
at that time yeah so people are like
yeah yeah [ __ ] them
and um
you know well they're out there robbing
and stealing because y'all [ __ ] it up
know that's that was kind of the
it was it was like the it's like the old
west in a lot of ways the old west might
have been beaten more peaceful actually
because the old west really wasn't like
the old west when you see it on tv
well i kind of feel like the old west
was like a lot more like
laid out and spacious yeah it's so it's
just kind of like you didn't get this
kind of because by this point like there
were you know big cities there was an
industrial revolution there was all that
and there was like much more widespread
poverty like a lot more people living on
top of each other there was a lot more
the old west was more like jeremiah
johnson
if you ever seen that movie
more kind of like the unforgiving
and um
would be another good example
i don't know that that
those are two good examples and and uh
more like piracy at the high seas if
you're out on the great plains with
great planes in the indians and stuff
uh it was more like being at sea but you
could drink that's the difference
because there's nothing but nothing out
there except salt water to drink but um
yeah
it's like being at sea
if somebody stole your horse it was like
stealing your boat you were [ __ ]
there's nothing out there grassland
lucky to find a buffalo well i mean [ __ ]
even nowadays
if you i've seen enough uh episodes if i
shouldn't be alive yeah even nowadays if
you're driving out in the desert
and you your car breaks down and like
you kind of go up yeah it really doesn't
take long
to like because i've seen like in the
modern day yeah where people had cell
phones and [ __ ] like that
uh still die like if their car broke
down on kind of a lonely road in the
desert because there's nothing there's
nothing around without equipment
training with no water
storage
yeah babies
three days in the desert maybe four
at desert temperatures
desert will [ __ ] you up
i'm deployed in the desert one of the
greatest deserts of all times out in
egypt
i love the desert
sinai desert
is beautiful like being on mars
but i had support and i had training and
i was young
i never survived hanging out with a
better one
great great people man the middle
easterners
great people man [ __ ] a lot of
a lot of [ __ ] culture man they had
their own individual culture
that was back in the it was back in the
90s
i did my time i'm [ __ ] i miss it but
i did my time that was in the past i
imagine that place isn't like that
anymore
i think shaw mel shake is [ __ ] built
up now probably like a big city now
a good look
but uh yeah man
i got some of that old school desert
that old school [ __ ] egyptian desert
kind of bring you closer to them
builders of the [ __ ] pyramids i can
understand it saw that [ __ ] it was
amazing
so yeah so like i said they kind of did
try to go out of their way to like visit
their families or like the families of
everybody that was in the game which is
kind of nice when you think about it but
maybe not the smartest move but it's
kind of nice
so they actually went to dallas in
september
to see their families they hadn't seen
them in a long time
at this point w.d jones who like i said
was kind of a teenager he said well i'm
just gonna go to houston you know my mom
lives there
now when he got there he actually got
arrested
for his part in the whole thing
uh on november 16th and he got uh you
know transferred back to dallas
now
throughout the fall
clyde
uh
committed a whole bunch of robberies
with some like other people that were
sort of local accomplices uh he did that
and his family and
bonnie's family took care of her because
like i said her leg was [ __ ] up so she
couldn't really walk
so they were kind of like taking care of
her and he was kind of going out like
stealing money and [ __ ] like that
now
when they were trying to they were
meeting with some family near uh i think
sours or sewers i'm not really sure i'm
not from texas so i don't know hey
pookie's on this show
what's up pookie she's like okay i'm
putting up with it i'm putting up coming
up here and [ __ ] chilling out with
the fat girl why are you so fat
shut up don't call her that
don't tell her she's not fat
she's not fat she's like shut up daddy
well she doesn't even care what you
think she's just she's just kind of like
[ __ ] you
she's like deal with it you're like a
wiener cat
oh yeah she can't help it
that's what pookie looks like front
pokey you shut up you're beautiful the
way you are yeah you're beautiful
jenny's got body positivity about the
cats i do
well why do you want to be mean to the
kids no i'm just i'm not being mean
either
she's heavy man she weighs a lot she's
like whatever this is me
she beats up beige
and beige is a lot well beige is just
bigger than her she doesn't weigh
anything well the thing about beige is
that she looks bigger because she's
super fluffy yeah she's not but if you
get her wet
you can see how much like skinnier she
is yeah beige is the paris hilton of
cats she's just looking this tall skinny
kitty
she just looks big because she's like
super super fluffy right she's a rag
doll actually yeah so she's like she has
like a dog she has big poofy hair yeah
like big luxurious yeah
fluffy hair and she and she thinks she's
just beautiful more beautiful than
anything she is beautiful she's
beautiful but she just walks around and
looks at you and just goes i'm beautiful
i'm beautiful yeah yeah she's wearing
shut up
and like any time you try to like and
anytime like pookie will like try to
play with her or something like that
she's just like i don't she's not going
to believe this one i can't really
believe this you are too ugly yeah i
can't believe it's happening right yeah
she's like
it's so hilarious like when we got
because i mean you've had beijing you
had beijing like before long time before
i met you yeah beijing's [ __ ] 12
years old maybe 12 or 13 yeah yeah
because she was like i think when i met
you she was like a kitten or a little
bit older than a kitten yeah and um
she so we had just beijing for like a
long time and then when we got pookie
i didn't realize like how different like
cat's personalities could be yeah
they're like completely opposite yeah
beige does not like pookie or at least
pretends not to like poogie they kind of
hang out sometimes yes they tolerate
each other we gotta get back to the
story we gotta we're going down we're
going down a kitty rabbit hole i mean we
can do that afterwards if you really
want to because i like to talk about
kitties but yeah
so yeah so what happened where was i all
right so there were a couple of like
other robberies and [ __ ] like that like
i said bonnie was at the her family and
also at clyde's family they were like
taking care of a leg because their leg
was all [ __ ] up and she couldn't go to
the hospital obviously
now they were trying to go uh and meet
with family members near
sours or sewers like i said i'm not from
texas i'm not sure how you pronounce
that
um
now when they were going to do that i
guess somebody got like tipped off
so they had some like
cops
like the dallas sheriff whose name was
smoot schmidt for christ's sake what
kind of name is that i mean no
no judgment i'm just asking what kind of
name is that i never heard that before
but it was that it was a couple of the
cops and they heard that they were going
to be there so they kind of like um you
know like waited an ambush for them
but clyde like drives up to the [ __ ] and
he's just kind of like
i kind of like this i don't feel good
about the situation like he somehow like
knew that this was a trap
and at this point because i think what
happened was that there was like a car
that was like left out and they were
like hey maybe clyde will like stop and
ask that person like what's wrong with
them and he just like drove into the
situation he's like i don't like this
so he basically um
he drove past the car that he was
supposed to stop and talk at at which
point the cops
just started shooting at the car
right
so uh
now there were other family members in
the car they didn't get hit thankfully
but what ended up happening was that all
the cops like shooting
at clyde's car
ended up hitting the car and went
through the doors
so some of the bullets
uh got
clyde and bonnie who was also in the car
like got them in the legs
now
this didn't kill them obviously or
didn't really like slow them down all
that much uh honestly but they kind of
like got out of that situation
yeah that's right a pookie stick that's
right tammy spooky's stick
and uh yeah taylor's been gone where the
[ __ ] has tila been
well tila can't always come by because
she has like work commitments and stuff
although she didn't say anything earlier
but sometimes she says oh i can't come
tonight no somebody said tina popped in
a while ago okay i didn't see that i
didn't see where to came in i didn't
either i'm like way behind in my chat
i'm still at the like sex spots yeah i
haven't got any new challenges
yeah i know
i don't know why i haven't got any new
[ __ ] it doesn't say that i haven't like
it hasn't shut down enough
good
it says it's still going okay i'm still
going right
here you go okay it's just my chat
that's behind yeah so if there's
anything that needs to be answered like
tell me because sandra hasn't been
around a long time she's gone
the germans got her
yeah what happened to sandra did she die
did she like develop a peanut allergy
and like die from all the peanut butter
that we told her
bless you bless you sweetie
cookie sneezed
but yeah okay
now she was in hawaii i didn't know that
oh [ __ ] okay okay
okay all right
yeah read me any like uh relevant
comments cause like i said after sex
bots i don't have any new comments i
don't know why it's not like updating it
doesn't say that i shut off or anything
like that but i don't i don't see
anything new after that
okay
so early 1934 remember how i said that
clyde his his big dream his big dream
was to get back
at the uh eastham prison farm
you know the place where he had
suffered so much abuse
so he actually did a big breakout
in january of 1934.
um so he got like a bunch of people out
of that prison that night
um so it was like this whole thing
now the raid on the prison
this was like a whole like the press
kind of came down on it it's like there
was a whole bunch of negative publicity
you know
what the [ __ ]
and clyde
this is what he'd always wanted to do
right i wanted revenge on the texas
department of corrections and it seemed
like he kind of got it
one of the guys that would later join
the barrow gang which is a guy named joe
palmer
he actually shot a guy during the escape
named major joe uh krausen and busted
him out of prison yeah yeah yeah that's
what i said this was like a big prison
break he went back to the place where he
got raped and all that other kind of
stuff and busted a bunch of people out
he hated that prison he attacked it from
the outside yep you'd never hear about
that today where dude does time in a
damn [ __ ] penitentiary and then he
goes back and goes i'm gonna come back
and attack that [ __ ] from the outside
talk about a grudge
[ __ ] was holding the grudge
against that place well like i said from
the outside i would admit that maybe
that was kind of what
i mean i'm not saying he wasn't a
criminal he was a criminal before he
went there he just didn't flame a petty
criminal he inflamed it but the fact
that he went there and he got treated so
horribly
that just made him like an even worse
criminal goes back to what i was saying
but you're making your own monsters
you treat people like that there's a
certain baseline in criminality that's
kind of low especially when times are
good
it's only idiots in there anyway
they don't tend to [ __ ] they get
pissed but then they forget about it
they're kind of low iq you start
throwing [ __ ] with 130 iq in
prison enough times 130 iq or 120 plus
iq all the time eventually you're gonna
get one that's gonna go like i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna do some crazy [ __ ]
when i get out of here
and he was springing people out of
prison from the outside attacked prison
from the outside
you just don't see that nowadays
i mean he was hot it was a special breed
back then he was mad it was because
they were intelligent and uh they didn't
have anything else to do
yeah what else are you gonna do i mean
they didn't really have any other
prospects in life back then no
like i said it's not like they couldn't
just move on it's not like nowadays it's
like oh i'll just start a youtube
channel right yeah they couldn't move on
because what are you gonna do right like
what are you gonna do right you have a
criminal record
right yeah actually they didn't um
having a criminal record back in those
days back in those days
fortunately didn't limit them
well that's probably a good thing
because a lot of people did have
criminal records back
that's it's fairly recent where all of a
sudden you got a criminal record so you
can't have a job you can't [ __ ] buy
guns you can't you lose all your rights
well that's something from the 70s late
60s well like i said nowadays i mean
most people
don't have criminal records yeah so it's
much easier to like hey if we're going
to give a job to a person let's give it
to this person that doesn't have a
criminal record and that doesn't mean
that you're not going to commit crimes
later because we hear all the time it's
like oh this person like didn't have a
criminal record and they went bad [ __ ]
crazy and like you shot up at school or
whatever but
i mean i don't believe in criminal
records
i it depends on what you did yeah it
depends on what you did if it was some
[ __ ] right and it depends on how old
you were
what the circumstances were what type of
criminal crime it is what type of crime
it is yeah if you're a a sex criminal
they tend to be serial sex offenders
because it's part of their damn sexual
it's part of their [ __ ] sexual
identity is go out for little kids or
whatever they're serial rapists or
syracuse that's very different yeah um
so they need to keep track of those guys
but it should be
and this is the way it always was in
american society until recently
you do a crime
you get arrested and convicted
you do time for it
you do your time and when you come out
you've now paid your debt to society you
get full restoration you're a citizen
again
you can vote
i mean
yeah you do if you didn't pay for your
crime then you need to be back and then
don't put them out don't let them out
don't let them out right
this whole thing about well you're a
felon and you can't have nah
that that was a huge because you're just
encouraging people to go back to prison
because if you get out it's like well i
can't get over a job there's no
redemption i can't get a job because i
have a criminal record and it's like
well [ __ ] i might as well go back to
being a criminal that's right you you're
creating a criminal class because
there's no redemption there's no path
back to normal citizenship you're never
qualified to have the full rights of a
citizen sure totally totally against
human rights totally
yeah i agree if if you committed a crime
do not let that [ __ ] out until
he's paid his price
paid his debt to society like i said
we're talking about like it depends on
what kind of crime it is depends on what
kind of some guys will never get
released some guys will get released
after 50 60 years when they're old men
okay he's paid he's paid he can have
full restoration of rights yeah it's
just it it's just that they have [ __ ]
the criminal justice system up [ __ ]
terribly i mean i'm a big fan of like
look if you just have like non-violent
kind of stuff like look i just like
stole some [ __ ] like they didn't hurt
anybody they just like stole somebody's
bike off the street
like that
yeah you should pay
but there it is
don't like don't let that like dog them
their whole entire life because you're
just encouraging people to like go
deeper into like criminality if you look
at statistics the only ones that you
have to watch are are sex offenders
sex offenders of a certain like violent
offenders yeah of any kind uh well no
because well depending on guys get in
fights guys [ __ ] start dueling each
other and it's a one-time thing it
doesn't happen again
because yeah that's different it's
different all right that's different if
you're just like drunk and you get in a
fight right right that's not the same
sex offenders
of a certain
type are serial sex offenders that's
that's who they have to [ __ ]
watch for
you know i mean serial rapists serial
[ __ ] child rapists that's that's who
they have to serial [ __ ] killers
that's the main threat
the rest of those guys
they can be dealt with on a case-by-case
basis
you rob a [ __ ] bag you do 15 years
you know what i mean
you come out you paid for it
if he hasn't paid for it then keep it
back in there for another five ten years
yeah i kind of feel like that's the
whole [ __ ] point that's the point of
[ __ ] prison if you're punishing him
you're punishing him then once you get
out you're free yeah then you should be
free but you're not though because you
still have the record right they
shouldn't do that i kind of i mean like
i said depending on you can have the
record but the record is only the only
the police and the courts know about
that that's nobody else's business it
shouldn't be like public no it's nobody
else's business
and that's the way it always was
but like i said [ __ ] like that
especially like non-violent crimes yeah
you know if you did like non-violent
crimes like i said especially like
drug-related [ __ ] or just like [ __ ]
kind of crimes yeah um
i don't really think everybody should be
known well the reason why i'm saying
that if you do your if you do the crime
you do the time you get your free
you go back to the 1800s and early 1900s
a lot of the some of the best law men
out there were ex-convicts
just because you did time doesn't mean
you couldn't be a cop that's that if you
trust the guy if you're a sheriff and
you trust the guy you go i'm gonna make
you a cop you're gonna catch bank
robbers
let him catch bank robbers
he knows what it's like he was a bank
robber yeah that's the kind of guy you
need you need a boba fett
you know well ned kelly even said that
he was like well he was using it as an
insult he's like
cops like to be a cop you have to like
know how criminals think so they were
exactly but like i said
sometimes people that did some crimes
when they were younger they're not like
that later on and then when they get
older sometimes they might make better
cops because they know
they've been there well not only that
one of the baddest [ __ ] gun fighters
of all times the [ __ ] they said
shot a man for snoring was john wesley
harden
and when he got out of prison he became
a lawyer
and he didn't commit any crimes after
that he was a celebrity
just he's a lawyer
you know yeah so people can change
and he didn't shoot the man for snoring
that's not what happened yeah that's
another that's just what they said
he was drunk in a [ __ ] hotel room and
the dude next to him that dude in the
room next to him was snoring his ass off
and he shot a [ __ ] pistol off into
the round while he was drunk
he might i get that
then he went back to sleep and then he
woke up in the morning they were waking
him up
accusing him of a murder he hit that
dude
with like what the bullet killed him he
was like i was drunk and it was just
loud and i was trying to sleep
like i said i get it yeah i get it had
it been murder
he would run
he didn't run he just stayed there he
was dropped shot the wall he did a bunch
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
shot a lot of dudes and
basically duels it came out of
self-defense because they wanted to kill
him he was a [ __ ] badass gunfighter
they kept coming at him
trying to kill him
but was he a criminal
yeah he was out of law he was outlawed
he was
john wesley he's not out of law but he
didn't really i don't think he was a
thief
you know
he was more like a serial gunfighter
they kept [ __ ] with him and he was
good
now some people go well you can't have
that everywhere this is [ __ ]
civilization no it isn't this isn't
civilization not the united states and
you already have that it's just that
they get picked up faster and it's a lot
more complicated now but you have that
kind of guy everywhere here and you
always will like i said you always have
to take everything and i know that we
don't really have the resources and blah
blah blah but it's like you really have
to kind of take everything on a
case-by-case basis it was case-by-case
[ __ ] because you don't really know
if that person that you picked up like
is this person really going to be a
threat like going for
probably not most of the time
i mean you never know though yeah
because there's always that one case
where oh we picked up this dude and blah
blah and then we released him and then
he murdered people like later on but you
know there's always going to be [ __ ]
like that because it's imperfect but
freedom is dangerous it's just how it is
it is there's all kinds of [ __ ]
because it's risk that's just how it is
if you want safety then that if you want
true safety then what you're talking
about is a totalitarian situation a
totalitarian government that [ __ ]
controls every bit of your activity
that's a maximum security prison you
don't want to live in that you are
living that you can go down the hood
today there's [ __ ] happening in the hood
shootings and [ __ ]
to where you go man three people were
killed in the hood we're not sure who
did it if you were there and saw how it
went down you probably understand it
good yeah
yeah yeah that's that's how that [ __ ]
went down i let that good dude go
it's
it's just more like law of the jungle
they might have been [ __ ] with that
dude
you know
and he knew who they were and it was a
long-standing [ __ ] feud
between dudes who were all kind of bad
and it was just a bunch of three bad
guys trying to kill another bad guy he
defended himself and ran
you know that's a lot of it
and it's just that
they'll never it'll never show up in
court because they're involved in the
drug trade
but you said well we can't have that
it's [ __ ] that's more control freak
[ __ ] that's none of your business all
right between bad guys they're sorting
it out
what the [ __ ] does a court care about
that and to be honest like i said if
they legalize they legalize drugs it
would go away legalized or at least
decriminalized right
a lot of that would go away it would
just go away a lot of that yeah a lot of
the gun crimes just go away all right
because there wouldn't be any no reason
for it and and the dea said this way
back on the war against drugs there
never should have been a war against
drugs
you guys know who i am if you're new to
the show [ __ ] i'm a veteran
[ __ ] served during times of [ __ ]
two wars
they're all [ __ ]
okay
um america loves [ __ ] jumping into
wars because the they make a lot of
money on it
one of the biggest mistakes was the
[ __ ] war on drugs and my mother was a
dea agent knew everything about i know
all about the dea
and [ __ ] everything that they [ __ ]
did
she's dea and state department my
[ __ ] family is [ __ ] deep in the
government
[ __ ] total [ __ ] they should have
just taken and they got good advice from
the [ __ ] dea back back in the 80s
they said don't
crack down hard on this
on these on cocaine and crack
control it like alcohol and it'll be all
right but no no no they didn't want to
do that they wanted to make a whole
industry on getting cops killed
and making drug dealers rich that's all
it did well in getting like
bystanders
killed
that's all it was
and then they pretended that it had
something to do with morality it never
did because those same politicians in
the [ __ ] congress that voted
to for the war on drugs invested in
drugs so they can make money on it they
were crooked as [ __ ]
yeah
you know and some of them ended up being
presidents the bushes and the clintons
were involved in that
yeah they made a lot of money on that
well like i said any time is i mean you
know prohibition probably the biggest
thing
it's the same kind of thing same [ __ ]
thing they should have made that [ __ ]
just like alcohol and controlled it
yeah i mean as long as it's
some people were like well how could you
control cocaine and heroin like alcohol
it's no different it's no different
there were people 100 years ago how
could you make alcohol legal oh the
world would end no it wouldn't it's just
booze
it's just booth i mean yes
obviously we're doing this show right
now
we're [ __ ] up but
yeah we're not driving we're not going
anywhere and no drug there's no drug
cartel getting [ __ ] rich off of our
drinking and they're not murdering cops
and murdering innocent people to to give
us that alcohol right and that's all
that's happening with the drug trade and
to be honest
i'm kind of like stupid look whatever
you want to do with your body you want a
drink
you want to take heroin you want as long
as you're not driving as long as you're
not in danger you're not other people
right like you know if you have a baby
that you're not feeding because well
obviously that should be taken away
right right but if it's just you
um
then i don't really feel like i have any
right to infringe upon it's
anti-american i don't i don't feel like
it is anti-american to um
illegalize those drugs in the way that
they did it
cowboys in the old west they had access
to [ __ ]
morphine
cocaine they had access to all that it
was called right to bliss
ain't that some [ __ ] the worst thing
about it is that i feel like
they weren't hurting other people over
there well yeah and like when i was in
the uk like in the 90s and 2000s and i
kind of feel like uh most of europe they
kind of got their [ __ ] together on that
issue they're like look
the drugs aren't legal
but they're decriminalized
like if you kind of like if you were
like a heroin addict for example they
wouldn't like put you in jail they
wouldn't do nothing like that they're
like well we'll put you on methadone
you'll be on a program we'll like watch
you and [ __ ] like that but they weren't
like
gonna like criminalize it i think they
should be legal and it was working out a
lot better i think they should be legal
just like alcohol but controlled
and then there has to be an
understanding among um there has to be
education to the young people that these
are addictive if you get involved in
this you know yeah it's like it'll
happen like this
just like they do with alcohol or
cigarettes or anything right exactly
that's it it should just be exactly like
that because it's essentially the same
thing and then it's essentially once the
corporations are involved the [ __ ]
once the corporations are involved the
profit margins will be tiny so drug
cartels will vanish it'll just be
corporations
they'll be selling it and it'll be good
quality stuff the prices will be low and
people will treat it like they do
alcohol i take this i can't drive well
that's what i mean i kind of feel like i
mean nobody is like killing each other
over there
[Music]
right because it's legal right but they
did back in the [ __ ] 20s of course
well that's kind of where the whole
gangster thing came that's what i'm
talking about
if you take stuff like that look look as
long as you make an effort to inform the
public look this is what this is this is
what it does right you're not allowed to
drive on it you're allowed to do this
that and the other like look if you have
a kid and you don't feed it because
you're on heroin or whatever yeah we'll
take your kid away like there are
consequences but
we don't criminalize it we're gonna put
people in jail and [ __ ] like that
because i kind of feel like that's like
what is the point of that it's not a
violent crime
and after a generation or two there will
be no interest in any of those drugs
yeah when i was in brazil there was no
real drinking age you didn't have i
drank at 14 or 15 down there but i
wasn't driving
and you get bored with it real quick
because nobody's stopping you there's no
glamour
well yeah the thing about it is that
they're drinking at the [ __ ] at the
dinner table wine and stuff well that's
it kind of happened in europe like in
france and stuff like that because kids
are like drinking wine like from a young
age it's not
taboo you're right so we're not like ooh
we're rebelling against our parents like
they're out we're gonna like drink all
their booze like they don't really have
that taboo as much i feel like in europe
so it's not as big a problem the same
when you go to peru cocaine everywhere
you can just go to the [ __ ] local
drugstore and get a damn matchbox of it
at least they could back in the 80s when
i was there
good high quality cocaine
they didn't abuse that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was there for [ __ ] hundreds of years
they care about cocaine
those white people are worried about
cocaine
but in peru well like i said making it
illegal you're making it you're missing
you're making a list and you're making
it attractive
to
people that it otherwise if you just
made it legal and it was just like a
part of the culture no one would give a
[ __ ] they didn't give a [ __ ] about that
[ __ ]
no
you're making it illegal so now
teenagers the world the country over
being like ooh i'm gonna like i'm gonna
piss off my parents i'm gonna do this
and then the other thing you know i mean
it's gonna be like that so
time name [ __ ] out we got all these
damn naked sex bots up in there
naked sex spots yeah [ __ ] they can't
spell gay yeah yeah we they spelled it
g-e-y g-e
that's that that's got the gay accent
along with getting gay
yeah but if you're gonna spell like that
it's usually i'm sorry but that's
usually
yeah yeah sorry
where's zach
i don't know zack isn't here tonight
danny rowling says there should be a
natural-born killers 2 film loosely
based on bonnie and clyde just saying
well i kind of feel like the first one
was kind of loosely based on them sort
of
but yeah
so uh so yeah so what happened so there
was like this big uh breakout
at uh eastham
uh prison farm
now during the escape joe palmer who
would later go on to join the gang for a
brief time
uh ended up killing
well he didn't kill him outright but
there was a guy named major joe kraussen
he shot him during his escape now the
guy
died like later like a couple days later
so he did and kind of ended up killing
now the thing about this big event
was that because clyde and his gang had
targeted eastern prison and had busted a
bunch of
inmates out of there
the law enforcement in texas were like
um
basically okay so everybody kind of came
to the party on this they were all like
we want to get bonnie and clyde
and the prison
uh
the guy that was like the [ __ ] uh
prison chief lee simmons
he says to
the dude that's like the
i don't know like the dude that was like
running the [ __ ] situation he's like
look everybody that's involved in this
we're not just gonna like catch them
we're gonna like
kill them
right
so they didn't even like they weren't
even interested in catching the people
they're like we just want them dead
we just want their dad
so
the thing about it is that one of the
people that escaped though was a friend
of
you know of uh clyde and bonnie kind of
this dude named uh who's
his last name is methmen
now this guy actually ended up being the
dude that would sort of like be their
downfall
you talk for a minute i gotta pick okay
where are you going i didn't he i didn't
hear the setup she just wants me to talk
she's got to go to pete yeah she's good
let me go to the comments i'm gonna go
to the comments and see what everybody's
saying
okay
murder hornet says well guys gotta go
gotta be somewhere at eight
they were crawling up in his booty
looking for cancer today now they're
gonna go down his throat look for cancer
he's talking about napalm in the morning
yeah strongholds talking about war is a
racket from smedley butler good good
book you can get the uh audiobook on um
uh youtube it's it's short about an hour
so
but you listen to that and now and you
go like well of course
kind of it's kind of basic [ __ ] by
today's standards
but one thing smedley does get in
get into he was a marine corps general
he gets into um all the banana wars in
central america
which i didn't know about those
all those little central american
countries that the united states [ __ ]
over
behind [ __ ] banana corporations
that same thing's happening now they
just [ __ ] do it in different ways
all that ukraine [ __ ] [ __ ] too that's
another [ __ ]
roger strong came out with a [ __ ]
documentary on that you guys need to see
it and they're trying to block roger
stone's documentary on ukraine although
it is on bishop see on bishop you'll
find out the truth of that that's just
cooking they
russia won that [ __ ]
okay
talking about all this [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] what's that pokey
she's sitting behind my chair talking
about war is a racket it's medley butler
okay she's bad i'm back yeah true
romance
strong like i said that yeah good movie
good movie
maybe we should review that yeah i gotta
get it i don't have it
um it was on
i want to buy that one it was on a
streaming service yeah recently yeah
yeah so there's this dude named methvin
who is one of the guys that they busted
out
and
there's conflicting stories it was
either like him and his dad like either
he
uh was approached by the cops and was
kind of like
yeah
help you set up an ambush
for the gang
um in return for getting like a complete
pardon for whatever my crimes were
or some accounts say that they
approached his dad first
and said hey your son will get a lesser
sentence
if you help us set up the thing it
doesn't really matter it's like kind of
like the the result was kind of like the
same whether it was him or his dad
he's like eating cookies
no
we got to eat after the show though yeah
i'm hungry because i'm kind of starving
but i still got a like a long way to go
i'm hungry
i'm hungry he's like a toddler i'm
hungry yeah
so yeah so what ended up happening
was that uh methane ends up like helping
to set up this ambush
so they contact
the former texas ranger
frank hamer
and he had been he had retired but he
was kind of still on the thing and he's
like we need you
to help us with this ambush that we're
doing like uh for the barrow gang
now he was kind of like
famous
for
[Music]
one having killed a lot of uh people
that he was like i think it was like 53
people
he had also been shot 17 times so there
was that
um so he had like a very formidable
reputation as just being like no
[ __ ] i'm just gonna like [ __ ]
shoot you or whatever 53 kills yet who's
like the [ __ ] feds hit man
basically i mean basically
um now interestingly even though there's
kind of a story that yeah he was the
first dude they approached because he
was like hey you're the man
but there is some evidence to suggest
that they actually went to two other
rangers first
but both of those rangers said no
because they said i don't want to shoot
a woman
because they knew they'd have to shoot
bomb
as well and there was still a thing
because bonnie was little and cute and
[ __ ] like that
and they kind of i kind of feel like
there was still a thing where they
thought that maybe she wasn't
they didn't want to shoot her you know
what i mean yeah i will say that i don't
know
even though there was some stories later
that like oh she shot this person the
other i don't know if she actually
really shot and killed anybody
she was there for sure i think she did
um
but
there was like a story later on that
it's like oh she shot somebody and like
oh she laughed when his head bounced on
the pavement or whatever but
uh most other accounts said no she was
sleeping in the car when that [ __ ]
happened so
i don't know i i think they were kind of
trying to like
maybe
make her look worse than she was like
after the fact i'm not really sure
i don't know if she actually like shot
and killed anybody but they're just
saying but nobody wanted to kill a woman
so there was that so they bring in hamer
and hamer is basically like
look man uh we're just gonna like kill
these [ __ ] because like i said
at this point like after the prison
break
they were kind of like we didn't even
care we're not going to bring them in
alive we just want to like [ __ ] shoot
them
so what they did it was easter sunday
april 1st 1934 uh what happened was
there was at the intersection of dove
road and route 114.
what happened there was a guy who's a
hybrid patrolman h.d murphy and another
guy named edward bryant wheeler they
stopped the motorcycles
and there was like a car there and they
thought that the car needed assistance
at this point clyde and methvin or
bonnie they're not sure
started open opening fire
there was a shotgun and handgun
so they killed both of the cops
now
according to an eyewitness maybe
uh bonnie fired the fatal shots maybe
although no one's really sure
methvin said
that he fired the first shot
but he wasn't sure
nobody nobody's sure what happened in
that situation
so at that point i think this is kind of
where the whole thing came from because
these shootings which came known as the
grapevine killings because it was
the town used to be called grapevine
texas it's called south lake now
but it was called grapevine back in the
old days
so the media kind of like super
exaggerated this
um
and this was the point where one farmer
who said he saw the [ __ ] said oh yeah
bonnie was like laughing and said look
at the way his head bounced like a
rubber ball like after i shot him and
[ __ ] like that but methvin later said
that i shot that guy that bonnie was
just like in the backseat of the car and
she didn't shoot anybody but i don't
really know like how
what the [ __ ] happened there
so that was like a whole [ __ ] media
circus
now one of the cops
um
was engaged to be married and i guess
his fiancee
attracted more media attention by
wearing her wedding dress to his funeral
and so obviously that got a lot more
media coverage
now
it didn't really matter though that like
a lot of the stuff was like later
discredited because the public what
strong dog says tom he's not a sicilian
but he is a good man okay thank you very
much
i'm not sicilian but i am a good man
okay
that's all you said yeah that's funny
but yeah so at this point whether the
media accounts were true or not
uh
mostly the public had turned against
the bonnie clyde at this point even
though like i said earlier on they'd
kind of been like romanticized a little
bit
um
so at that point there was a reward of a
thousand dollars
not even for the capture for the dead
bodies
of the great fine slayers that was quote
they didn't want them captured they just
wanted them dead
um and the governor of texas ma ferguson
at that point also added another reward
of 500 for each of the two killers
so at that point uh
ever since everybody believed that she
was that bonnie was the one that had
killed uh h.d murphy
this was the first time that the uh that
there had been a price on her head so
there was that
now uh public hostility
got a lot worse a couple days later
when clyde and methvin
murdered another dude
a 60 year old man constable william
campbell
who uh this was in oklahoma
now what had happened was that they
kidnapped a police chief named percy
boyd
and they crossed the line the state line
into kansas and then they let him go
they gave him some money and some
clothes
and [ __ ] like that
and boyd ended up identifying clyde and
bonnie to the authorities but he didn't
know who methvin was so he was just like
a john doe at the time
so at this point
i feel like the public had did not want
to believe that bonnie was actually like
a killer
but because of all of this evidence that
was mounting whether it was exaggerated
or not people were finally starting to
say to see that you know yeah she could
like shoot and kill people too whether
she did or not i don't know
but
the public started to perceive that so
they started like turn against them
where they had been kind of romanticized
before
um in a cartoon
in the dallas journal
there was actually
a cartoon of like
an electric chair
and it had like a little sign on it that
said reserved for bonnie and clyde like
on the [ __ ] electric chair so there
was that
so mayhem 1934
clyde had 16 warrants outstanding
against him multiple counts robbery auto
theft theft uh escape assault and murder
in four different states
so hamer
had started tracking the gang in back in
february
and he had found out that what they were
doing as we mentioned earlier because
they knew of the whole thing where you
can't like catch people if they go like
from state to state they said okay well
this gang has been exploiting
that fact
so what they would do was that they
would exploit the state line rule
you know uh officers couldn't pursue
somebody over a state line like it you
know into somebody else's jurisdiction
now they did kind of go around like in a
spiral movement they were trying to like
visit everyone's family they were doing
that kind of [ __ ] but
um
hamer kind of figured out like what they
were doing
so he kind of had a good idea where they
were going to go
next
so he got uh he got together like along
with methvin who had like uh was one of
the ones that they had busted out of uh
easton but also he had like later turned
against them
so
they set up an ambush posse
so hamer's posse was like six men total
like including him four of them were
texas officers and two of them were
louisiana officers
so they figured out
the posse
they figured out they're in shreveport
and then they're like well clyde and
bonnie are going to be visiting ivy
methvin who was i think like methan's
dad
and in louisiana
so they set up an ambush
along louisiana state highway 154
and so they're in place now there's kind
of like it doesn't really matter what
day it took place but they're just kind
of like it was somewhere around may 22nd
or may 23rd somewhere like that
so about 9 15 in the morning may 23rd
the posse's in the bushes
and they're kind of like they've been
there for a long time and they're just
kind of like what the [ __ ] like nobody's
going to come along what the hell is
going on we're bored
and then finally they see this car
driving toward them high speed
now what ended up happening was that
they had put
methvin either methane or methane zidade
they had put him in a car
and they said well put it on the
shoulder of the road so it looks like
you're having car trouble because they
think because clyde knows you like he'll
stop and be like hey man what's wrong
so they wanted to do that
so they did that
so
what they did so the car is coming close
and it's clyde it's his ford v8
and clyde was driving
now he did slow down to see what the
[ __ ] was going on with this car because
he recognized it
now
when the car slowed down
the cops
asked no questions they immediately
recognized that car and they just
started shooting
you know what i mean they didn't like
like i said they didn't even i mean i
was i hoped that they would be sure that
that was that car it would be sad if it
was just like some random citizen that
happened to have the same car was
speeding but it wasn't uh happily it was
clyde
so he slowed down a little bit and the
cops just [ __ ] started shooting and
honestly they had plugged so many like
[ __ ] bullets into that car they're
like by the time it got even with them
i'm pretty sure that both of both uh
clyde and bonnie were probably already
dead
because they [ __ ] riddled that [ __ ]
with bullets uh clyde got shot in the
head
pretty much died instantly um from one
of the first shots
uh because the car kind of like went
past them and then it kind of like went
into a ditch but they just kept like
kept shooting kept shooting kept
shooting
uh the cops fired 130 rounds
emptying each of their weapons into the
car
uh so they were kind of like well i kind
of feel like they were feeling like well
hey we've shot at these [ __ ]
multiple times in the past like maybe
not them but the cops had shot at them
multiple times in the past and they were
still running around
so they're like we uh one of the cops
said yeah we weren't taking any chances
we just like shot and shot and shot
until like all of their ammunition was
empty pretty much they just kept
shooting
um now they did actually take some film
footage you can see it on on youtube i
actually watched it earlier
um one of the deputies this was
immediately after the ambush 112 bullet
holes in the vehicle
about a quarter of these
struck
um clyde and binding clan
uh as i mentioned earlier
the coroner whose name was dr wade
he listed 17 entrance wounds on clyde's
body 26
on bonnie's body including several head
shots
and another shot that had severed
clyde's final column
and as i mentioned earlier in the show
uh the undertaker bitched because he had
a hard time bombing the bodies because
there were so many bullet holes that the
embalming fluid kept leaking out
i've seen pictures of the bodies on the
slab like i've seen pictures of the car
with the bodies inside i've seen videos
of the car with the bodies inside it
doesn't look that
grisly because it's black and white
and i've seen photos of like
them in the mortuary they don't like
their faces don't look that bad like
their bodies are covered up but
i mean you can tell they're dead but it
doesn't look that [ __ ]
gross
but apparently they were [ __ ] like
riddled with bullets also the officer
shot so many that they were all like
partially deaf for a time so there was
that
so they go into the death car
and they found a whole [ __ ] arsenal
of weapons
stolen automatic rifles
semi-automatic shotguns uh sawed off a
bunch of handguns several thousand
rounds of ammunition
uh 15 sets of license plates from
various states so there you know there
you go they found all kinds of [ __ ] in
there
now what ended up happening after this
though
was that because all of the cops were
like hey we we killed bonnie and clyde
it's over and they all like ran to
you know
the phones to like call their bosses or
whatever and say hey we did it
and so the public found out about it
and because this was the 1930s
a huge crowd gathered
and they all immediately
started like stealing [ __ ] from the car
they always do this um
one of them like somebody was trying to
like cut off clyde's trigger finger
another person was trying to cut off his
ear
a bunch of people were like just
stealing like bits of clothing and [ __ ]
like because they were gonna sell that
[ __ ]
so people talk about shipping like oh
the good old days yeah [ __ ] that
these people were like [ __ ] they
swooped in like vultures ooh can i take
like some body parts i could sell that
[ __ ] on like eat boy you couldn't sit
all on ebay back then but obviously it
was just kind of like well i'm gonna
sell this
nobody was like grossed out nobody was
just like ooh they're famous i'm just
gonna get in and like somebody was in
there trying to like cut off locks of
bonnie's hair and [ __ ] like that even
though it was all covered with blood
[ __ ] like that
cutting off a piece of her dress
tons of people in there doing kind of
[ __ ] like that and so sold them as
souvenirs later on so like i said good
old days
that's what people did back then
um so yeah
so it yeah it was like a [ __ ] circus
now again the the car
i kind of feel like
i saw the car and i'm glad somebody like
mentioned it earlier in the comments
because i know that i saw bonnie and
clyde's death car
as a kid
and i couldn't remember where i saw it
and he said yeah it was at
ripley's believe it or not in saint
augustine and i was like well that must
be where i saw it because i went there
like a lot as a kid and i know that i
saw that as a kid so that's probably
where i saw it
so uh interestingly
this whole so they take the bodies to
you know the mortuary which was actually
the mortuary or the undertaker was in
the same
business as the furniture store which i
guess was like pretty common back then
which is weird but it makes sense
because
furniture store it's wood you make
coffins blah blah blah so there's that
so they kind of took in the back and
they said that the population of the
town where this happened
was originally 2 000 people and then
they had an extra 10 000 people like
show up like a few hours later like
looking for
everything like they they all just came
in there like converged on the place and
like everything went up like all the
prices of the beer went up everything
went up
kind of like back in the day when they
have executions they start yeah selling
off [ __ ]
condiments and [ __ ]
not condos i mean they're just taking an
advantage they're like look some like
famous [ __ ] happened we're like gonna
make some money
that's what happened
so
there's there's that so yeah a lot of
people came in now bonnie and clyde had
actually they knew they were gonna die
they kind of like i said had a suicide
pact kind of thing like not officially
but they kind of had to think where they
knew that was gonna happen
they wanted to be buried next to each
other
but
bonnie's family said nah we're not doing
it um
she's like i i think her mom even said
look uh clyde had her while she was
alive her family's gonna have her when
she's dead all right
so they took her
uh back
and buried her leg with the family clyde
was actually buried i believe next to
his brother buck who was also killed
like earlier on in their crime spree and
they're kind of like under a shared uh
tombstone that says
gone but not forgotten uh i think that
was something that clyde wanted on there
so there was that
um interestingly
thousands and thousands there's video of
this too because like i said it was only
1930s
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people turned up to see the funerals
i mean there's like a line you can see
like the funeral home like where they
have to think there's like a [ __ ]
line around the block like a people that
came to see the bodies it's crazy
um they said they got flowers from all
over the place uh some of the gangsters
pretty boy floyd and john dillinger who
would actually like be killed a few
years later dillinger was one of the
main ones he was a badass he got killed
like only a couple years after bonnie
and clyde did i think and pretty boy
floyd got killed too like
a lot of them got killed like later on
him and
nelson baby face nails what was his name
baby yeah baby charles nelson charles
nelson i don't remember what his first
name was it's just baby face yeah
he didn't like that if you called him
babyface he'd kill you
isn't that funny
that was something that came from even
though everybody just remembers that
yeah i think you got like a cool
nickname then somebody called him baby
face to his face and [ __ ] doing one
of those robberies and i think he shot
him if i remember correctly like hey
thank you she never called me i know you
he hated that
i think his name is charles nelson
call me charles goddard yeah
i mean i could see that yeah like
because usually like if people give you
a nickname it's usually something that
you really really don't like about
yourself you're right i would imagine if
i remember correctly [ __ ] charles
nelson was a world war one fat if i
remember he he didn't play
another he was like this he was a gang
he was a
motorized bandit
one of the funniest things was that
uh this is from wikipedia
the largest floral tribute was sent by a
group of dallas city news boys
uh the reason they sent it was because
the murder of or you know the the
slaying of bonnie and klein
had sold 500 000 newspapers in dallas
so i guess they were kind of like happy
that's like thanks for the publicity or
thanks for like selling all his papers
so they sent like a big huge
which is weird but they sound like a big
huge floral thing to their [ __ ]
uh future george nelson was his name
okay george nelson
yeah interestingly i found this
interesting too
um
so the ins
interestingly both bonnie and clyde had
insurance policies
and the insurance companies paid out on
them
but i guess
since then i don't know if it was
because of this case particularly but
they don't do this anymore
um
if you have a thing nowadays like
insurance policy like life insurance if
you've been involved in criminal
activity and get killed as a result of
that criminal activity i guess they
don't pay out for that anymore
but back then they did
so
there was that
also interestingly
the men on the posse that killed bonnie
and clyde the six dudes
they were supposedly they were supposed
to get
one-sixth each of the reward money
so this was supposed to be 26 000 i
don't know if that's total or if that
was like what they were each supposed to
get which would have been like a big sum
back then
but the thing about it was that most of
the companies that had like put that
money up said like now we don't want to
pay that now like now that it actually
happened
so each of them ended up getting about
200 bucks
and they said oh well if you want to
like collect anything off the death car
you can do that
so they did
um a couple of them
like one of them got like clyde's
saxophone because he was a saxophone
player
like they just like stole [ __ ] out of
the car and like had to sell it for
[ __ ] which is crazy that's crazy
but yeah so
there's the whole thing so after that
like some of the other members of the
gang
uh most of the other members of the gang
eventually got killed
uh in various other things
and i think just one of them like
survived maybe it was just kind of the
thing but like i said it's just kind of
funny how
i don't know i just kind of laughed at
the whole thing about like the cops they
were just kind of like hey you can just
like scrounge [ __ ] out of their death
car
one of them took like some like a tackle
box with like fishing [ __ ]
well it was over it was [ __ ] crazy
well they were supposed to get some of
the reward money they didn't even get
that they didn't get that which you know
for the time you know what i mean they
didn't think it was a big deal yeah
i mean just take that whatever
they should
they got like 200 bucks here here's 200
bucks which i don't know how to how much
200 bucks was back then that was
probably like
a couple thousand it's like here have a
saxophone and like a tackle box full
yeah
that's crazy that's great funny
it is
but you know
and uh as i mentioned earlier blanche
who was buck's wife like buck died
obviously like during the spree
but she survived she actually went to
prison for a little while i think it was
like six years or something like that
she was the one that was like partially
blinded by the glass
and while she was in prison
she wrote a memoir about her time with
them
and a friend of hers
found it like much later on like in her
attic or some kind of [ __ ] so that was
actually like published later on so she
actually had a diary of like all this it
wasn't a diary she didn't write it at
the time but she wrote it like a a year
or two afterward
and she kind of like uh wrote about what
it was like
being on the road with them all the time
so it was um from her it was where a lot
of that stuff came was like oh it wasn't
glamorous at all and they were like
fighting all the time and you know it
was like really not
fun because they were just like living
in the car and they were just at each
other's throats all the time so there
was that
but uh the death car as far as i know i
saw it when i was a kid because like you
said it was at ripley's in st augustine
which is still there by the way and
ripley's is still fun because i just
went there like last june
but um 1988 a casino
uh near las vegas
bought the death car
for about a quarter of a million dollars
uh and apparently still hasn't and as of
this year the car
and the shirt that clyde was wearing
when he was killed
um is at this place called the prim
valley resort and casino in prim nevada
on interstate 15. so if you want to see
it
that's where it is that's where it is
so as i mentioned uh henry meffen who is
the guy that had conspired to like help
out with the ambush
he actually ended up escaping
prosecution for the grapevine texas
murders because he you know turned
against uh bonnie klein
but he got prosecuted for other crimes
in oklahoma which i believe was uh also
a murder and he got convicted and served
eight years there like i said blanche uh
ended up serving six years and she got
out and they found her
diary later on so what happened in 1935
was that uh federal authorities and the
police in dallas they arrested and tried
20
family members and friends
of clyde bonnie and clyde for aiding and
abetting so this was known as the
harboring trial
all 20 either pleaded guilty or were
found guilty the two moms clyde's mom
and bonnie's mom
got jailed for 30 days
other sentences ranged from two years
imprisonment to one hour imprisonment
that was like an hour that was for like
one of the teenage girls or something
like that
uh so there was that
so that's pretty much like i i kind of
think that's probably about it right and
like i said
after i kind of feel like it was
a big deal at the time but after the
movie came out in 1967
there was like renewed interest i feel
like in the case because it was very
romanticized people thought it was like
this big love story which i guess it
kind of was but probably not really
i don't know by all accounts it was but
it's also like super [ __ ] up but
running around in a damn car with no air
conditioning [ __ ] on dirt roads and
it wouldn't have been very romantic it
would have been like being in the field
in the army
but see the thing about it was that back
then everybody was in the same situation
that's true so it was around nobody
really had it wasn't like nowadays where
it's like what you don't have any air
conditioning or like place to shower
right back then nobody did nobody did so
everybody had like a lot more
everybody's a lot more forgiving and
people like being
being stinky or like a little unhygienic
i guess yeah i guess
all right so uh
let me probably go ahead and shut it
down i'll make it something you ready
i suppose so all right we've been like
three hours and 40 minutes i'm trying to
like look and see if oh you're like been
a good show
yeah we had a good time and we mostly
stayed on topic yeah we did
most of the time hopefully you guys
enjoyed that which is crazy which is
crazy
yeah this was a fun show i had a good
time like researching all of that we'll
be back when
friday night for the side tracks show
but we'll have live streams uh tomorrow
or the next day no friday friday okay
that's what i just said okay all right
friday that's right
[Laughter]
all right
thank you all for dropping by this
evening thank you for your super chats
hopefully you enjoyed the show this
evening i try to stay on topic as much
as possible so we will see you guys
again on friday night for our side track
show on which we do not have to worry
about staying on topic because we just
talk about whatever
so hopefully you guys will join us again
on friday evening
and we'll see you all then thank you all
for dropping by we will see you later